euh
je vais te donner une leçon
sur deux sujets qui accompagneront
vous tout au long de votre vie personnelle et
vie professionnelle désormais
et qui vous a toujours accompagné dans
le passé qu'on appelle
l'énergie et le changement climatique donc je ne suis pas dedans
un
du monde académique mon travail est d'être
un consultant
je suis associé dans un cabinet de conseil et je
avoir un deuxième emploi en tant que
un président d'une association et je fais
vulgarisation scientifique qui a conduit
à ce cours et explique pourquoi je le fais
ce travail plutôt que
mon travail lui-même le cours que je vais suivre
vous donner est essentiellement basé sur
données d'observation relativement simples
raisonnements
et j'espère qu'il sera accessible c'est
pas très différent pour être honnête
à partir de certaines choses que je dis dans d'autres
formulaires au public
qui n'ont pas été méticuleusement sélectionnés
par une université
examen d'entrée donc il devrait vous devriez
arrivent normalement à suivre
je vais quand même vous rappeler deux ou
trois petites choses dans l'introduction
d'abord que tu te souviendras de ce que je suis
dire beaucoup plus facilement si vous prenez
Remarques
pendant que je parle même si tu vas jeter
à la poubelle après car
prendre des notes est un super souvenir
deuxième chose est que je vais vous inviter
pour toujours
résoudre les problèmes en raisonnant par
ordres de grandeur et en utilisant la croix
règle de multiplication
tu es entré dans cette école après avoir été
soigneusement sélectionnés pour votre ci-dessus
capacité moyenne à résoudre des complexes
problèmes
avec des données d'entrée exactes et complètes
nous vous avons sélectionné pour entrer dans ce
l'école en vous posant des problèmes qui sont
inéquitable
ils n'ont qu'une solution ils
peut-être un peu compliqué mais ils ont
une seule solution et ils sont bien
posé
c'est-à-dire que dans la déclaration vous
avoir toutes les informations pour trouver
solution
la vie et ce que je vais te dire à partir de maintenant
est essentiellement constitué de courrier malade
problèmes
pour lequel vous n'avez pas tous les
information
et quand on s'attaque à un problème qui est
mal posé euh
et que nous n'avons pas tous les
information il y a quelque chose qui est
extrêmement efficace pour y remédier
questions et c'est particulièrement vrai dans ce
je vais vous dire ce qui est à la raison
par ordre de grandeur et
règle de multiplication croisée et
partout dans la vie si un sophistiqué
le modèle ne correspond pas à un bien mis
règle de multiplication
règle de multiplication croisée puis le modèle
est faux
ce sont les quelques éléments que je donne
vous en préambule de ce cours
que nous aurons le plaisir d'aller
à travers ensemble
voici l'un des retraités les plus célèbres
en france donc
il est à la retraite parce qu'apparemment il a dit
il allait s'arrêter
fonctionne mais ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai
parce que de temps en temps nous le voyons
faire des choses moins marrantes que ça
c'est pas grave on va le mettre
remis en service lorsque
vous posez une question qui veut être un
millionnaire pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
déjà regardé cet excellent
jeu nous euh vous donnons quatre réponses dans
avance c'est-à-dire qu'on vous dit
l'étudiant qui est assis là dans le
deuxième rangée a-t-il une chemise qui est
un b bleu
vert c jaune d noir
puis tous ceux qui dorment dans un sac
cacher et les autres
avoir la bonne réponse ici nous allons
imaginez qu'il pose une question ouverte
c'est
il te demande ce qu'est l'énergie tu sais que
en france il y a un ministre de l'energie
afin que vous puissiez lui demander ce qu'est l'énergie
normalement il devrait savoir puisqu'il est
puits du ministre de l'énergie
vous vous rendriez compte si vous si vous pouviez
posez une question et je vous donnerai un
exemple en peu de temps mais en fait
la première réponse qui vient à l'essentiel
d'une population et je dis la plupart des
population
je ne parle pas du monde dans lequel
vous vivez au quotidien
c'est que ma facture d'électricité c'est si
vous dites
l'énergie dans un certain nombre d'endroits
particulier
dans des endroits qu'on qualifie de général
public les premières pensées qui viendront
dans l'esprit de beaucoup de gens
et c'est normal car c'est aussi
la première façon dont l'énergie est présentée dans le
monde de l'économie
c'est que c'est quelque chose qui peut être
acheté une commodité
donc le sujet principal est de savoir si
c'est cher ou pas cher
et si nous pouvions faire les choses différemment pour
avoir la même chose pour moins cher
c'est particulièrement vrai dans l'actualité
dernièrement puisque pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont
suivi ces types de mouvements
vous savez que cela a commencé sur un
différend sur le prix des carburants
bien sûr ce n'est pas la principale raison
bien
mais il a commencé par son différend
qui est un différend sur le prix de
carburant
les gilets jaunes n'ont jamais dit qu'on ne voulait pas
consomme du carburant car il produit trop
beaucoup de co2 ou on ne veut pas consommer
carburant parce qu'il nous rend dépendants
la russie ou la norvège nous ne voulons pas que non
non ils ont juste dit
c'est trop cher ce que je vais essayer
vous expliquer pendant
une partie de ce cours est que si vous
prendre le problème
sous cet angle malheureusement tu manques
le point
et il y a plusieurs raisons pour lesquelles nous manquons
le point le premier est que
si vous regardez strictement en termes économiques
à ce que ça coûte
acheter de l'énergie par rapport à ce que vous gagnez
et vous pouvez le représenter de plusieurs manières
une des façons dont je peux le représenter
est de euh regarder ce que ça coûte chaque
année
à l'ensemble de l'économie pour acheter le pétrole et le gaz
et le charbon qui l'alimentait
donc je regarde l'ensemble du produit économique
de l'année et je regarde par rapport à la
produit économique ce qu'il en coûte
acheter sur le marché l'ensemble des
l'huile que nous avons consommée l'année précédente
le gaz que nous avons consommé dans l'année
et je parle du monde dans son ensemble
bien sûr et l'ensemble d'un charbon qui
a été consommé l'année
et le résultat auquel je suis arrivé est
qu'il ne coûte que quelques pour cent de ce que
nous gagnons
seulement quelques pour cent je vais vous montrer un graphique
et pas trop longtemps sur ce que ça coûte
le français
acheter de l'énergie et je vous assure que
opérateurs téléphoniques payants que je ne ferai pas
nom pour dire hey je suis en retard ou où tu es
euh ça coute globalement le même prix pareil
prix
cela coûte quelques pour cent de ce que vous gagnez
et à partir du moment
lorsqu'un objet placé dans un
le débat ne représente que quelques pour cent
d'un débat, le réflexe normal sera de
dire que je vais m'en occuper seulement un
quelques pour cent du temps
généralement ce que vous voyez alors dans le
les débats politiques est
je m'intéresse à l'énergie pendant la
élections pour quelques pour cent du temps
puis le reste du temps je donne ça à
quelqu'un à qui je délègue le problème
et dis-lui
prends soin de sa merde par toi-même euh
ce
assurez-vous simplement que cette chose est gérée
ce n'est pas vraiment mon problème
voir le lien avec les pensions avec
diplomatie avec politique économique
ou avec le nombre d'imprimantes qui
il y a dans le pays que je ne vois pas
le
connexion donc je considère juste cela comme un
sujet détachable du reste
qui ne nécessite que quelques pour cent de notre
temps ce que je vais vous dire à partir de maintenant
sur
est que ce raisonnement est aussi pertinent que
si je te disais ton cerveau
est de deux pour cent de votre poids afin que je puisse
débarrassez-vous en pour vous ce n'est pas grave
vous perdrez deux pour cent d'inefficacité
donc le raisonnement est en tranches de tarte et c'est
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus large que
la question du raisonnement énergétique en tarte
les tranches ne vous diront jamais si le
tranches dépendent les unes des autres ou
pas
un autre raisonnement amusant de ce type est
dire que l'agriculture représente deux pour cent de la
pib
donc on s'en fiche on s'en débarrasse
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance
ouais sauf si vous arrêtez de manger le
restant 98 du pib
très vite l'arabe va devenir
problématique
donc avec des raisonnements en tranches de tarte toujours
faites très attention ils ne représentent pas
la dépendance que vous pourriez avoir de
une tranche à l'autre et ce que je vais
pour vous montrer désormais, c'est que le
dépendance de la
97 ou 95 d'un pib qui n'est pas de l'énergie
acheté
sont en fait totalement dépendants dans
monde moderne
des cinq pour cent en question
donc l'énergie n'est pas une facture plus exactement
ce n'est pas qu'une facture
même si euh c'est comme ça qu'on raisonne dans le
monde économique dans lequel nous vivons
une autre pensée vient souvent à l'esprit quand
en parlant d'énergie ce sont les
les gens qui te disent ah énergie le bien
l'énergie est celle que nous économisons
la deuxième chose que je vais t'apprendre
dans ce cours est que si vous êtes
en ce moment dans cette pièce avec le
temps au choix pour dormir pour ceux d'entre vous
qui font la sieste ou pour écouter
au lieu de récolter des pommes de terre est
précisément parce que le monde a
se gorgeait de plus en plus d'énergie
durant les deux siècles qui viennent de
passé
le résultat est que le monde dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui
est un monde d'énergie croissante
l'abondance et pas du tout un monde de
augmentation des économies d'énergie
en fait la bonne énergie dans le sens de
celui qui a permis l'émergence de la
civilisation industrielle
dans lequel nous vivons est précisément boom one
nous n'avons pas épargné
troisième sujet très en vogue au
l'instant c'est que
ce n'est pas important de savoir quelle énergie
est ce qu'il est important de savoir, c'est qu'il
deviendra 100 renouvelables
vous verrez qu'en fait ce n'est pas
exactement comment les choses se sont passées
en fait la bonne façon d'aborder l'énergie
peut-être celle d'un poète
l'énergie est ce que vous êtes rempli sur un
matin
quand vous vous sentez bien ou un
l'après-midi selon l'heure à laquelle vous arrivez
en haut
sur euh ben cette façon de voir les choses c'est
en fait le bon
parce que quand on considère être plein de
énergie cela signifie que nous considérons
ayant une grande capacité à maîtriser notre
destin
j'ai beaucoup d'énergie je suis en forme
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a pas grand chose qui me fait peur
donc j'ai une grande capacité à contrôler mon
destin
mais l'énergie comme vous le verrez désormais
en avoir beaucoup c'est justement avoir
une grande capacité à maîtriser ses
environnement
c'est que par définition par définition
avoir beaucoup d'énergie, c'est avoir un grand
capacité à maîtriser l'environnement
et pourquoi est-ce parce que l'énergie avant
être une facture ou un débat
le sujet du débat est une grandeur physique
tu sais que c'est bien puisque tu devais partir
à travers pas mal de physique pour arriver à
l'école
l'énergie est une quantité physique c'est
assez marrant d'ailleurs
parce qu'en physique il n'y a pas totalement
définition inéquitable de l'énergie je vais
vous en suggérer un pour moi l'énergie c'est quoi
quantifie le changement d'état d'un
système
ok l'énergie est ce qui quantifie je dis
quantifie
ou calcule le changement d'état d'un
système en d'autres termes
plus un monde autour de vous change
plus l'énergie est entrée en jeu
et plus l'énergie entre en jeu, plus
plus le monde qui vous entoure est transformé
c'est aussi simple que ça donc si je le ramène
aux transformations du quotidien
ou plus exactement aux objets qui
transformer l'environnement au quotidien
vie
voici des objets qui transforment
température ces objets
sont utilisés pour tendre à changer les températures
ce que je vous montre ici donc soit pour
chauffer ou refroidir
ces objets utilisent ou éventuellement restituent
énergie
voici des objets qui servent à changer
la vitesse d'une voiture
seulement cette utilisation, il est utilisé pour changer le
vitesse de ce qui est contenu dans la voiture
vous éventuellement et votre valise si vous
valises si vous partez en vacances
eh bien un changement de vitesse est un changement de
état d'un système
voici des objets qui servent à
changer une forme que vous avez
tu avais de la terre la terre est creusée c'est
placé à côté du trou
changement de forme tu avais une tôle
la feuille est tamponnée et vous avez un
couloir
changement de forme utilisé par ces machines
de l'énergie tu as de l'énergie qui entre en action
lorsque vous modifiez une composition chimique
d'ailleurs le premier produit chimique
composition qui change constamment
fournir de l'énergie dans votre environnement est
appelé digestion
d'un aliment que vous mangez en fait votre nourriture
sert à vous fournir de l'énergie
tu as de l'énergie qui entre en jeu
quand vous avez un champ magnétique qui
interagit avec un courant électrique que vous
peut-il peut
soit pour ainsi dire consommer dans un moteur ou
fournir de l'énergie
dans un alternateur vous avez de l'énergie qui
entre en jeu lorsque vous réorganisez
nucléons dans un noyau
et tu sais que vason passe son temps
Faisant cela
c'est une grosse bombe thermonucléaire permanente
qui passe son temps
assembler des noyaux d'hydrogène pour fabriquer
noyaux d'hélium
tu as de l'énergie qui entre en jeu
quand vous avez un rayonnement de matière
interactions
donc l'interaction de rayonnement de la matière qui
qui vous intéresse le plus est votre
téléphone intelligent
mais de toute façon il n'y a pas que celui-là
il y en a un qui va nous intéresser
le tout en quelques mois
rayonnement solaire à la plage comme le montre
cette femme là
donc en général utiliser de l'énergie est
rien de plus que transformer le monde
autour de nous
et inversement transformer le monde
autour de nous suppose nécessairement
cette énergie est entrée en jeu
une fois je vous ai dit qu'un premier petit
remarquez bien pour que vous sachiez qu'à la
moment où nous avons un
ministère de la transition énergétique non
juste un
ministère de l'énergie, nous avons un ministère de
puits de transition énergétique le ministère de
la transition énergétique est probablement la plus ancienne
ministère dans la communauté des hommes
car cela fait 500 000 ans que
les hommes sont en transition énergétique
Il y a 500 000 ans la seule énergie humaine
pouvait utiliser était leur énergie corporelle et
puis ils ont commencé à domestiquer le feu
première énergie extra-corporelle
dans les temps anciens commencerait à
domestiquer toutes les énergies renouvelables et
même d'ailleurs certaines énergies fossiles pour
exemple le pétrole était connu par les
sumériens
le charbon était connu des chinois quelques
il y a mille ans
évidemment à petites doses et donc
la révolution industrielle a été
domestication de
combustibles fossiles nous y reviendrons donc
donc
la transition énergétique est une constante
état des hommes
chaque fois qu'ils trouvent un moyen d'utiliser un nouveau
source d'énergie ils le font
ce qui caractérise l'époque moderne et
nous verrons
qu'il le caractérise d'une manière extrêmement
façon forte et que c'est ce qui cause un
problème
c'est que nous avons radicalement changé la
ordres de grandeur dans tous ces
processus en très très peu de temps
espace de temps énergie
je vous ai dit est une quantité physique à dire
que l'énergie est une quantité physique signifie
ce
il y a de nombreuses chances que l'énergie soit
régis par des lois que nous ne pouvons pas
changer c'est le charme
des lois de la physique, vous pouvez
comprendre ce que mac gonfle les équations
sont mais une fois que vous avez compris, vous
ne les changez pas, vous ne pouvez pas simplement
dis oh ce serait bien pour un achat
pouvoir des consommateurs si nous pouvions changer
eux un peu
pas la peine d'essayer en ce qui concerne l'énergie que vous
avons des lois qui s'appliquent à nous
et que nous ne pouvons pas changer ce qui ne change pas
signifie que nous n'essayons pas de le changer
de temps à autre implicitement par des votes en
parlement
mais tout de même il vaut mieux savoir
lui je t'ai dit que l'énergie est ce qui quantifie
la transformation sur le
de l'environnement le premier cardinal
loi qui est
très facile à retenir en termes de
énergie et que vous connaissez tous par cœur
cours
c'est le premier principe de
thermodynamique loi de conservation
d'énergie
cependant appliqué aux hommes la loi de
la conservation de l'énergie a un effet extrêmement
conséquence simple
les hommes ne peuvent rien faire de mieux que d'extraire
l'énergie qui existe déjà
dans l'environnement et l'utiliser pour elle
avantages c'est tout ce que les hommes
sont capables de faire si les hommes étaient capables de
apporter de l'énergie
sans interaction avec l'extérieur
monde que nous violerions
le premier principe de la thermodynamique
je suis sûr de tout bon harry potter vous
peut le faire mais dans le monde réel
c'est plus difficile donc toute l'énergie que nous utilisons
nous devons le trouver dans l'environnement
du tout une énergie qui est
dans l'environnement est appelé un primaire
l'énergie dans le jargon de
les compagnies d'énergie alors quand vous voyez dans le
statistiques que je peux vous demander de regarder
au terme énergie primaire
cela signifie que c'est l'énergie telle qu'elle est
trouve dans l'environnement
il y a un autre terme qui est très
commun en énergie et nous y reviendrons
ceci en quelques cours qui est la finale
énergie l'énergie finale est celle qui
passe dans le compteur du consommateur final
et qui est le consommateur final c'est vous
quand tu es à la maison et que tu as un gaz
compteur ou un compteur électrique
ou si vous avez un réservoir d'huile qui est très
dommage tu ne devrais le dire à personne
et un compteur sur le camion qui livre
vous le carburant ou
quand tu travailles dans l'industrie et que tu
avoir un compteur parce que vous utilisez du gaz dans
un four en verre et ainsi de suite
dès que vous êtes un consommateur final
particulier ou industriel
et vous achetez de l'énergie qui vous permettra
faire fonctionner une machine ça s'appelle une finale
énergie
et l'énergie trouvée dans l'environnement
on l'appelle l'énergie primaire et dans
entre les deux évidemment tu as le
système énergétique historiquement le seul
énergies primaires que l'homme sait
utiliser
est la nourriture et aussi la chaleur du soleil je devrais
ont aussi mis le coucher du soleil
donc historiquement le seul convertisseur qui
les hommes ont à leur disposition est eux-mêmes
parce que pour consommer de l'énergie il faut
convertisseur dans lequel vous devez le mettre
quelque chose qui va le transformer
donc le seul converti que les hommes avaient
est eux-mêmes donc ils mangent ils frappent
eux-mêmes sous le soleil
et de ces énergies qu'ils absorbent
ou ingérer émerge
déteste beaucoup le travail mécanique un peu
ensuite avec le temps nous commençons à pouvoir
domestiquer
d'autres convertisseurs en dehors du bois un très
convertisseur rustique nous avons commencé à
domestiquer toutes les énergies renouvelables possibles
énergies
les énergies renouvelables comprennent à l'époque
autre
organismes vivants parce qu'ils sont
complètement renouvelable
les animaux de trait sont parfaitement renouvelables
ils mangent de l'herbe parfaitement renouvelable et
vous offre donc parfaitement
énergie renouvelable
le vent et l'eau ont également été
domestiqué à travers
moulins l'ancienne europe était couverte de
moulins utilisant
l'eau que le vent donc tu dois voir ça
les énergies renouvelables ne sont pas l'avenir
mais le passé
pas dans le sens où il n'y a rien à
attendre de l'avenir, mais ce que je veux dire
est que les énergies renouvelables étaient
tout autour de leur vie quotidienne quelques
il ya des siècles
un monde de 100 énergies renouvelables que je connais très bien
bon à quoi ça ressemble
j'ai au moins un point d'échantillonnage c'est
le monde il y a trois siècles
celui-ci est 100 renouvelable ça marche très bien
Bien
donc un monde avec un milliard d'hommes bons
terre 30 à 40 ans d'espérance de vie
à la naissance
et les deux tiers de la population du
domaine
je sais que ça marche avec 100 renouvelables
énergies
il n'y a pas de problème depuis que nous l'avons fait
une fois
de toute évidence, le débat d'aujourd'hui est de savoir si nous
parvenir à faire de notre civilisation en utilisant
les ingénieurs des vésicules et les
machines que nous utilisons aujourd'hui avec 100
énergie renouvelable
et nous y reviendrons plus tard et
il y a deux siècles, de grands ingénieurs
et certains grands physiciens ont dit
nous pourrions utiliser d'autres convertisseurs convertisseurs
eux-mêmes non renouvelables
dans ce cas des machines en métal
et nous obtenons nous pourrions leur donner à manger
énergie
qu'on ne sait pas encore utiliser
à grande échelle qui s'appelle
combustibles fossiles
là je vous résume en une diapositive
quelle a été l'histoire énergétique de
humanité
d'abord le convertisseur c'est nous alors il y a
d'autres organismes vivants et esclaves étaient
une partie d'entre eux d'ailleurs
puis énergies renouvelables et infini
machines métalliques avec des combustibles fossiles quoi
je te dis aussi ce qui est quelque chose
très
absolument essentiel est qu'en fait nous
ne pas consommer d'énergie en dehors de ce que nous
manger
quand tu vois la consommation d'énergie
quelque part c'est un terme impropre
car à moins que je ne me trompe et que je ne le fasse pas
pensez que vous avez déjà bu du pétrole si
quelqu'un ici m'a alors fait savoir mais
normalement non
je ne pense pas que tu aies déjà mangé du charbon de bois
peut-être juste celui qui donne des flatulences
ou que vous avez respiré du gaz et non du méthane
en tout cas mais peut-être
on vous donne la voix de mickey alors nous le faisons
ne pas consommer d'énergie avec notre propre organisme
en fait quand on
dire que nous consommons de l'énergie c'est un
terme impropre mais mais c'est un terme impropre qui
induit une illusion d'optique qui
extrêmement fort
consommer de l'énergie est en fait
domestiquer une machine
donc partout où vous voyez la consommation d'énergie
y compris dans mes diapositives parce que de temps en temps
et puis j'utilise les raccourcis même si
j'essaie de l'éviter
vous barrez et remplacez par l'utilisation de
machines et partout où vous voyez
nous consommons de plus en plus d'énergie
vous rayez et remplacez par nous sommes
utiliser de plus en plus de machines
c'est ainsi qu'il faut l'entendre dans
fait
la quantité croissante d'énergie que nous sommes
utiliser n'est rien de plus
que l'augmentation en proportion due de
l'énorme exosquelette mécanique qui
nous avons créé à notre profit
c'est l'énergie et ce monde de
machines est le monde que vous
vivre à moins que je ne me trompe encore
les mœurs et le temps te fait venir
cette salle de classe avec des vêtements
si vous êtes habillé cela signifie que vous avez
mettre un vêtement à un moment donné
ou un autre
enfiler un vêtement prend
très exactement même si vous êtes très
maladroit quelques secondes dans le noir mal
réveillé après avoir ingéré des substances que je
ne nommerai pas
peut-être quelques dizaines de secondes mais jamais
beaucoup plus longtemps quelques secondes
ben en quelques secondes tu t'es mobilisé
à votre profit
des milliers de machines sans toi
s'en rendre compte
mais vous avez mobilisé des milliers de
machines à votre avantage vous avez
commencé par mobiliser à vos profits
le tout via des machines agricoles qui ont
si tu as
vêtements textuels dits naturels
coton lin etc vous avez commencé par
mobilisant à votre profit tous les
machines agricoles que nous avons
cousu récolté et éventuellement traité le
coton
si vous utilisez un textile synthétique
fibre tout ce qui commence par poulie
quelle poulie
nylon etc tout vient du pétrole
si tu mets un sous-vêtement c'est ça
a du synthétique
fibre ou un t-shirt qui contient du synthétique
fibre tu es
mettre un morceau de plate-forme pétrolière plus
le vapocraqueur
plus la raffinerie tu connais ces petits
bête de cinq milliards d'euros
tu observes dans le coin de sa photo
si vous avez autre chose qu'un
tissu écru
c'était teint il fallait
fabriquer les matrices de sorte que le produit chimique
l'industrie s'est modernisée en amont
et puis nous avons eu désolé euh nous avons dû
tisser les fibres commençons par ça
donc
machines mécaniques, il fallait
alimentation donc l'industrie chimique
et il fallait le transporter
parce qu'évidemment ce n'est pas là que
le coton est cultivé
qu'il est tissé et mort etc autre
des machines sont intervenues à
toutes les étapes intermédiaires de la fourniture
chaînes appelées trains de camions
et avions
il a fallu fabriquer des lieux
dans lequel nous installons
raffineries où nous installons des produits chimiques
usines etc ces machines ont aussi
entré en action
les centrales électriques devaient alimenter
une partie de l'énergie pour le processus
ces missions entrent également en action dans
bref quelque chose de totalement inoffensif
que nous faisons comme nous respirons qui s'appelle
mettre un vêtement
tu ne t'en rends pas compte mais il y a un
armée de machines qui ont travaillé pour vous
juste pour ce simple geste
après s'être habillé ceux qui ont
une bonne hygiène se lavera les dents
après le petit déjeuner bien sûr encore c'est le
même chose
se brosser les dents est quelque chose qui
prend disons trois minutes si vous
suivre les conseils du médecin
une minute si vous êtes pressé vous avez
encore
utilisé des quantités considérables de machines
juste en faisant cette tâche simple
ici vous avez une photo d'un produit chimique
usine du nord de la france qui
appartient à la
groupe familial fusée
et qui a produit un sucre qui peut
se trouver dans
un dentifrice appelé sorbitol donc tu sais
ce
le sucre donne des caries donc si vous en mettez
dentifrice
sucre qui provoque des caries ce serait un
Dommage donc le sucre que l'on met dedans
dentifrice
de sorte qu'il a un peu d'un agréable
le goût est un sucre qui ne cause pas
caries c'est un
molécule différente en fait c'est l'une des
quelques centaines de molécules que vous allez
sortir d'un
usine dite amidonnerie dans laquelle
vous entrez dans un train rempli de wagons
chargé de maïs tous les jours et sortir
des centaines de produits chimiques différents
et de ce côté il y a quelques
mille personnes travaillant
cette usine tourne tu sais 24h/24 et 7j/7 et c'est
l'une des plus grandes usines chimiques de
France
alors votre tube de brosse à dents est en plastique donc
ouais les tubes ne sont pas vraiment en métal
plus si plastique
encore une fois l'équipe des raffineries de plate-forme pétrolière cracker
etc.
et votre tube en plastique n'apparaît pas
grâce à l'esprit saint donc vous avez besoin d'un
extrudeuse
que vous pouvez voir ici vous brossez votre
dents devant un miroir parce que
sinon tu mets des taches partout
donc il fallait faire du vermeer voici un
train complet qui fait un miroir
et encore faut-il les cartons les camions
etc.
vous vous lavez les dents avec de l'eau purifiée
et c'est par exemple une machine à
purifier l'eau
alors encore une fois une armée de machines a travaillé
pour
votre geste quotidien appelé brossage
dents
et maintenant j'arrive au plus important
objet de ta vie
ton téléphone c'est pareil quand tu fais un
appel téléphonique, vous avez mobilisé une armée de
Machines
pour vos prestations il fallait
fabrication
plastiques pour le téléphone à fabriquer
eau purifiée etc.
il faut faire de l'acier pour l'antenne
soutien
vous avez 40 métaux différents dans un
smartphone 40
certains présentent extrêmement bas
concentrations néanmoins plusieurs
des dizaines signifient autant
activités minières ici et là et
machines minières, etc.
dans un réseau de télécommunications qui le rend
possible d'utiliser le smartphone
parce que si vous êtes le seul à avoir un
smartphone et les autres pas
ça ne sert pas à grand chose sauf si
tu joues au jeu du serpent
sinon vous devez communiquer avec
d'autres qui nécessite un réseau ici est
par exemple une machine qui fait passer des câbles
faire le réseau
et ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite pour fabriquer un téléphone
l'appel est aussi quelque chose qui mobilise
des milliers de machines
pour toutes les étapes intermédiaires de
construction et fonctionnement d'un appareil
donc je le répète aujourd'hui
nous vivons dans un monde de machines et tout
les machines sans
exception utilisent de l'énergie tous
et vous comprenez que pour inverser le
raisonnement que je vous ai montré plus tôt
c'est trois pour cent du total donc ça
n'a pas d'importance
si tu prives instantanément le monde
d'énergie ce n'est pas trois pour cent d'un
pib tu vas perdre
c'est assez simple de te comprendre non
ont plus
transport fonctionnel que vous n'avez plus
banques
plus de réseaux d'eau plus d'hôpitaux
pas plus
transporter quoi que ce soit parce que plus
énergie
alors tu meurs de faim tu meurs de froid et
vous vous entretuez
en gros c'est ce qui se passe si
demain matin instantanément on se prive
le monde de l'énergie
donc le monde entier le tout moderne
le monde en dépend
si cela coûte un pour cent ou 100 de
ce que tu
gagner n'est pas vraiment un sujet eh bien c'est un
sujet mais c'est loin d'être le seul
sujet
à partir de maintenant, nous allons entrer dans un
nombre d'éléments quantitatifs
comment l'énergie est-elle comptée, vous savez que
quand vous donnez un exercice à
entrer dans ce cool
en général l'unité que vous êtes
autorisé à utiliser et le seul est
le bijou
je l'utiliserai très peu car si je
expérimenté en joule
les tailles que nous allons approcher
désormais
il y aura tellement de zéros sur la diapositive
que tu mettrais trop de temps
il suffit de le regarder si souvent que nous utiliserons
unités d'énergie qui sont un peu
différent du joule
permettant d'éviter les gigas
et vegas
et ça permet d'avoir des choses plus petites
première façon de supprimer six zéros de la
bijou
est de passer au kilowattheure pour que le
le kilowattheure a un avantage, c'est que
c'est ce qui apparaît sur vos factures même si
l'énergie n'est pas
juste une facture et ça permet aussi d'avoir
plus proche des choses qui sont plus familières
dans les discussions quotidiennes
un français utilise aujourd'hui la prise
tout en compte
y compris les importations, c'est-à-dire y compris
l'énergie utilisée
à l'étranger pour faire évoluer les machines
qui se nourrissent
la consommation en france donc pour prendre le
exemple précédent de votre smart
téléphone il est fabriqué ailleurs dans sa
intégralité
c'est environ 60 000 par an
kilowattheures concernant l'énergie
entreprises, ils ont une unité qu'ils
aussi comme qui leur sauve quatre autres
zéros qui est l'équivalent d'huile de ton
la tonne équivalent pétrole a un sens très simple
définition c'est l'équivalent
de l'énergie dégagée par la combustion
d'un ton d'huile
une tonne de pétrole n'a pas toujours la
même énergie de combustion
cela dépend de la nature de l'huile que nous
généralement généralement ajouter
de qualité moyenne et ça vaut 11
600 kilowattheures de temps en temps vous
sera
ont également des unités qui sont amenées
des anglo-saxons notamment par les
les Américains
et vous savez que les unités américaines sont
rarement compatible
avec le système métrique
oui donc la tonne équivalent pétrole rentre dans
cette grande image
je vais utiliser un peu la voûte électronique
bit
mais pas souvent et finalement j'utiliserai
l'équivalent esclave qui est à peu près
100 kilowattheures de mécanique
énergies et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi tout de suite qui a déjà fait ça
ici dans cette classe
vraiment seulement ce nombre ou sont les autres
timide alors qui a remonté l'eiffel
la tour
ah là beaucoup mieux on imaginera
ce
pour quelque raison que ce soit
Vous intéresse
tu décides de gravir la tour eiffel
6,3 fois pendant la journée
qui a déjà grimpé la tour eiffel
6,3 fois
ah on y va il y en a un parfait
était-ce pour impressionner les touristes japonais
ou sans raison
d'accord donc si vous montez 6,3 fois la
tour eiffel en journée
la tour eiffel étant un peu dépassée
300 mètres tu auras gravi
jusqu'à environ 2 000 mètres par jour
si je me souviens que le calcul fonctionne
car c'est un peu plus de 300 mètres
euh, ce faisant, vous utiliserez généralement votre
jambes depuis l'utilisation
tes bras sont plus durs
l'énergie mécanique que vous allez
restaurer avec un effort de sa nature
ce qui n'est pas un effort totalement marginal
pour une personne moyenne
utiliser de l'énergie est égal à la masse fois la hauteur
fois g formule c'est
extremement simple ca donne un rendu ridicule
demi-kilowattheure sur une journée
donc un homme au travail qui utilise ses jambes pour
alimenter un appareil mécanique
quoi qu'il en soit comme charlton heston qui
colporte en vert de soja
bien à la fin de la journée, il est capable de
restaurer
ou prévoir de l'ordre d'un demi
kilowattheure d'énergie mécanique
si vous imaginez que cet homme au travail
fait cet effort tous les deux jours qui
est une autre façon de dire
qu'il escalade la tour eiffel trois
fois tous les matins
d'ici la fin de l'année sa dentelle sera
ont fourni une centaine de kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique
donc sur un an de travail le corps d'un
homme raisonnablement formé
est capable de fournir de l'ordre de
une centaine de kilowattheures de mécanique
énergie
s'il utilise ses jambes si vous utilisez vos bras
et
en passant un peu ton dos aussi
et une pelle parce que c'est plus difficile
à mains nues et que tu dégages six
mètres cubes de terre
soit environ 15 tonnes de terre
en un jour
et en plus de beaucoup d'ampoules vous
aura fourni 0,05 kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique c'est-à-dire que
tu es 10 fois plus ridicule de la
personne qui a grimpé trois fois
tour eiffel avec ses jambes
donc une paire de bras au travail pendant la journée
c'est
0,05 kilowattheures
et une paire de bras qui fonctionnent plus d'un an
c'est environ 10 kilowattheures de
énergie mécanique si vous brûlez un litre
d'essence qui coûte outrageusement
prix élevé d'un euro 60
ce qui justifie qu'on le trouve aussi
cher vous obtiendrez
10 kilowattheures d'énergie thermique
et si vous voulez avoir un strict
comparaison évidemment il faut le faire
passer par une machine qui convertira
l'énergie thermique en mécanique
énergie
même avec les meilleurs ingénieurs du
monde pour faire des voitures dont certains disent venir
de cette école
vous obtiendrez deux à quatre kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique
non plus ça ne dépend pas du
l'ingénierie cela dépend de la façon dont la voiture
on exploite les deux à quatre si c'est dans
proche des performances de pointe ou non
eh bien oui tu sais donc si c'est proche
à deux c'est le conducteur
la faute n'est pas la tienne
vous obtiendrez donc deux à quatre kilowatt
heures d'énergie mécanique
donc à partir d'un seul litre d'essence
dont nous verrons dans peu de temps que
les français consomment encore
pas loin de euh 1 000 litres par an
c'est la même quantité de travail
capacité à changer l'environnement
comme 10 à 100 jours de travail forcé d'un
être humain
donc je le redirai différemment quand
vous utilisez une machine qui consomme
litre d'essence
vous pouvez modifier l'environnement
c'est fournir du travail
au même niveau que 10 à 100
les humains qui utilisent les jambes ou
leurs bras
si vous ne savez pas si vous vous rendez compte
différence que vous avez entre le
l'énergie utilisée par les machines et par
nos propres corps
si nous convertissons tout en argent un autre
façon de dire la même chose est que
pour obtenir ce kilowattheure de
énergie mécanique si je paye un homme
au travail pour le fournir ça coûte quelques
une centaine à quelques milliers d'euros
de l'autre côté la machine au travail
fournit le même service à un prix marginal
coûte et je ne compte pas le prix d'un
machine à l'intérieur
de quelques dizaines de centimes donc quand je passe de
le réseau à la machine au travail
sans le coût d'une machine
j'ai divisé le coût d'une unité
transformation dans l'environnement par une
facteur de quelques
centaines à quelques milliers
la raison pour laquelle nous mécanisons tout ce que nous
peut dans le monde économique est
là donc dès que tu peux
remplacer un roomboy par ruba
vous le faites dès que vous pouvez remplacer un
travailleur sur une chaîne d'approvisionnement par ruba
tu le fais dès que tu peux mécaniser
quoi que ce soit
un agriculteur par exemple et le remplacer par
votre tracteur vous toujours toujours
faites-le toujours à cause de cela absolument
considérable
différence de prix entre le travail humain
et énergie
c'est une raison pour laquelle nous avons toujours
pensé puisque nous avons des machines performantes
remplacer
des hommes avec des machines c'est même entré en jeu
pour les remplacements d'esclaves
si vous prenez un esclave qui en général est
pas une vocation de jeunesse
le faire pour le faire travailler tu vas
devoir aller le chercher contre son
sera
donc vous devez payer de l'argent je vous rappelle
qu'il fut un temps où
le commerce des esclaves était un commerce
entreprise complètement complètement immorale
dans leurs critères actuels
mais en attendant c'était fait pour
raisons économiques
tu dois l'empêcher de te tuer
il faut l'empêcher de s'échapper
tu dois le nourrir etc
et quand on regarde ce qu'il en coûte
obtenir le travail d'un esclave
tu réalises même que ça va coûter
vous 10 à 100 fois plus que le
machine
qui n'a rien contre son état
comme une machine qui n'essaie pas d'obtenir
le diable hors d'ici qui ne continue pas
grève qui marche
24 heures sur 24 donc la raison pour laquelle l'esclavage
disparu dans les sociétés qui avaient
l'accès à l'énergie ce n'est pas
parce que notre code génétique a tellement
je vais faire un petit détour dans un
cours auquel certains d'entre vous ne sont pas allés
ce n'est pas parce que notre code génétique a
modifié
notre code génétique est exactement le même que
nos deux ancêtres deux ou trois
il ya des siècles
tout simplement il n'y a plus d'incitation à
faire des choses
nous faisions à l'époque parce que nous
trouvé beaucoup mieux
et beaucoup moins ennuyeux de faire pareil donc
quoi
a libéré les esclaves est essentiellement du pétrole
alors à ce stade je vous en propose
conclusions initiales
que euh je vous propose ou vous rappelle donc je
rappeler qu'utiliser l'énergie suppose
cette énergie
existe déjà dans l'environnement donc
quand dans un débat tu entends des gens qui disent
nous devrions utiliser de l'hydrogène hydrogène dans le
environnement il y a un endroit où
il y a
beaucoup de ça s'appelle le soleil mais
ce n'est pas très facile d'aller le chercher
pour le repos c'est partout dans des formes liées
donc dans l'eau
il y en a plein ou dans la vie etc mais
c'est partout sous forme liée
il n'est donc pas disponible en tant qu'énergie
source la molécule est disponible mais la
énergie
non tu dois briser les liens donc pour
exemple par
électrolyser l'eau et pour cela vous
besoin de plus d'énergie que l'énergie que vous obtenez
d'une combustion d'hydrogène
donc l'hydrogène n'est pas une énergie primaire
source quand on vous dit que nous pourrions utiliser
les piles à combustible euh les piles à combustible sont fondamentalement
des moteurs mais pas des sources d'énergie
donc ce qu'il faut comparer au primaire
énergies que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
sont d'autres énergies primaires qui sont
choses que l'on peut trouver dans
environnement
et qui peut être utilisé tel quel dans le
le reste n'est pas disponible
donc puisque l'énergie quantifie
transformation
vous n'avez pas d'énergie verte et d'ailleurs
pas d'énergie rose pas plus que
énergie noire en fait pour choisir une énergie
est de choisir un type de transformation
et c'est choisir les avantages et
désavantages
toute l'énergie est sale si vous l'apportez à un
niveau d'utilisation suffisant
le jour où tu couvriras toute la planète avec
panneaux solaires photovoltaïques
il cesse d'être propre donc énergie propre
en général quand on regarde les chiffres
vous réalisez que c'est une énergie qui est
utilisé en quantité suffisamment faible pour
que ses inconvénients
sont aussi petits en général
c'est de l'énergie propre dès que le
énergie
commence à être utilisé en quantités massives
quel que soit le mode d'extraction du
environnement
il y a des inconvénients
choisir une énergie c'est arbitrer
entre les inconvénients que nous voulons et ceux
nous ne voulons pas
c'est le sujet
quelque chose qui est absolument essentiel, je
y reviendra plusieurs fois
pendant le premier module du cours
est-ce l'énergie et je ne parle pas
sur ce qui nous permet de l'extraire de
l'environnement
l'énergie est gratuite vous avez tous entendu
le vent est libre d'un soleil et libre là
il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas l'utiliser
en fait le vent et le soleil
sont libres
personne dans cette pièce ne nous a payé un seul
sou pour
la victoire pour exister ou pour la cascade
existent mais personne d'autre dans cette salle n'a
payé un seul centime pour
le pétrole pour exister est gratuit
ce qui n'est pas gratuit c'est
consentement d'une personne qui a eu la chance
être assis dessus pour lâcher prise
cela coûte de l'argent et quel est le coût
travail de quelques-uns d'entre vous qui iront au
ancienne entreprise au total
ce qui est très mauvais ne le dites à personne
aller faire des trous dans la terre pour obtenir le
sortie d'huile
ça coûte de l'argent le pétrole c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit
alors, quand vous payez pour l'énergie, vous
le salaire est un travail humain et l'intérêt sur l'homme
capital
accéder à une énergie gratuite
nous ne payons que des hommes et pour le reste de l'argent
ne sert qu'à payer les hommes
vous n'avez jamais vu mère nature envoyer
une facture à n'importe qui
donc on ne paye que des hommes
puisque l'énergie est physique et puisque quoi
vous payez n'est pas l'énergie elle-même mais le
travail
qui doit être consacré à son extraction
de l'environnement
le prix d'une énergie ne dépend pas
sur l'abondance de
une énergie elle-même parce que nous pourrions dire
si une énergie est très abondante
certainement il devient encore plus libre que
les autres en fait
ce n'est pas ce qui compte
si une énergie est très abondante, elle peut
encore difficile de l'extraire
l'environnement
tu sais qu'il y a une énergie qui est
totalement servi dans l'univers c'est le
rayonnement de l'espace vide c'est trois
degrés kelvin
je peux vous assurer que vous ne ferez jamais
quoi que ce soit, même si c'est
absolument contre
en quantités considérables, de sorte que le fait que
une énergie est en quantités considérables
ne dit rien sur la facilité de
l'extraire et l'utiliser pour notre
avantage
ce qui comptera pour le coût de l'énergie
c'est la facilité de l'extraire et
l'utiliser à notre avantage
est le fait de savoir si le préexistant
source d'énergie dans l'environnement
est déjà très concentré et avec
quelques barrières
nous séparant de l'axe de la
source
l'archétype de l'étoffe est l'huile l'huile est
super concentré plus que le reste
à part le nucléaire mais le nucléaire
c'est plus compliqué à utiliser c'est super
concentrée et les barrières qui
nous séparer
de son accès ne sont pas très difficiles à
traverser vous savez historiquement
Mr Drake est allé faire des trous gratuits dans
titusville et l'huile
la gestapo donc ce n'est pas très compliqué
historiquement pour obtenir du pétrole
plus une énergie est séparée de
nous
par de grandes barrières le plus et le plus
c'est diffus
plus ça coûtera cher à extraire
ça vient de l'environnement c'est juste
physique je vais vous montrer un peu rapide
comparaison imaginons que je prenne le
volume d'air dans cette pièce qui n'est pas
très loin dans des ordres de grandeur à un
cube de coté 10 mètres
imaginez que je le rends bleu à 80 ans
kilomètres par heure ce qui représente
ce choix pour la marijuana est un bien
mistrial et pour les marins 45 nœuds de
vent
et je passe ça à travers une éolienne
si je passe ce vent à travers un vent
turbine ça va
mettre mon éolienne en mouvement et
fournissez-moi de l'électricité
cette électricité est dans l'énergie donc je peux
comptez la quantité d'électricité qui
je reçois de mille mètres cubes de
l'air à 80 kilomètres à l'heure qui
passe gratuitement l'éolienne est la même que
la quantité d'énergie que je reçois de
brûlant
trois millilitres d'essence
gratuit pas gratuit tonnes pas trois litres pas
gratuit
30 litres trois millilitres gratuits minuscule
millilitres
quant à la quantité de travail humain à
être investi dans votre opinion
est-il plus facile d'aller faire un trou dans
désert saoudien
et faire sortir trois millilitres d'huile
ou est-il plus facile de construire une éolienne
attendant que le vent souffle et récupère
l'électricité qui en sort
eh bien la réponse est dans le prix puisque
l'argent ne paie que les gens
si vous utilisez une éolienne, vous
L'Europe 
payez votre kilowattheure d'électricité
de six à huit centimes
à la sortie d'une éolienne et à
ce prix je
ne donne cours que quand le vent souffle quand
il n'y a pas de vent le vidéoprojecteur
ne fonctionne pas il n'y a pas de micro
peu importe je peux
le faire avec mes mains ou parler un peu
plus fort mais par contre ceux de
toi qui est venu avec le métro il n'y a pas
métro non plus
ce qui peut être plus un problème il y a
pas de fête même ce soir si le vent le fait
pas souffler
ça commence à devenir vraiment vraiment
ennuyeux à ce stade et il n'y a pas
réveil demain matin s'il utilise
électricité
vous savez que le réfrigérateur ne peut pas refroidir
bières et cetera c'est
c'est un vrai désastre donc s'il n'y a pas
vent le système s'arrête
si vous voulez que le système ne s'arrête pas lorsque
il n'y a pas de vent, vous devez ajouter le coût
de stockage
et donc à ce stade vous essentiellement
multiplier par trois parfois par six
donc l'ordre de grandeur du stocké
kilowattheure avec vent
c'est quelques dizaines de cents par rapport à
que l'ordre de grandeur du coût
du kilowattheure déjà stocké
depuis quand tu enlèves l'huile du
le sol est déjà un stock
que vous pouvez utiliser aujourd'hui demain le
le lendemain après-demain
la semaine prochaine à 3h exactement quand vous le souhaitez
bien ce kilowattheure de pétrole déjà
stocké tout droit sorti d'un désert saoudien est
vaut 0,3 cents
donc entre le coût du kilowatt
heure extraite du vent et diffusée
source
c'est pas dense on est à 1,2 kg par
mètre cube
ce n'est vraiment pas dense et le coût d'un
kilowattheure tout droit sorti d'une huile saoudienne
Bien
vous avez un facteur de l'ordre de 100 sur
le coût de la fourniture du stock
kilowattheure
et même là l'éolienne que tu as faite
avec
huile le système n'est pas fermé mais doit
dis ça
pour fabriquer l'éolienne que vous avez
a bénéficié d'un outil industriel performant
système
qui vous a fourni l'extraction de
cuivre de la mine
extraction de minerai de fer à partir de bauxite
la mine
métallurgie amont l'assemblage de tous
ce gâchis mais transporte le béton
blocs érigés, etc.
tout cela a été fait avec des combustibles fossiles si
tu devais faire tout ça
avec d'autres éoliennes, ce n'est pas le cas
tout à fait certain que le prix de
l'énergie éolienne serait toujours
six à huit cents par kilowattheure nous
peut prendre les paris
je parie que ce sera un tout petit peu
plus cher donc même faire
éolienne utilisant des combustibles fossiles vous
réalisez que vous avez un facteur de quelques
des dizaines à 100
entre un kilowattheure du vent
et un kilowattheure d'une huile facile
Bien
et c'est irrémédiable parce que c'est
la physique
donc c'est pour cette raison mais
historiquement nous ne sommes pas passés de
combustibles fossiles aux énergies renouvelables, mais nous avons
fait exactement le contraire
il y a deux siècles la marine était de 100
renouvelable
et d'ailleurs comme le vent n'était pas
soufflant toujours tu dois prendre des citrons
à bord pour s'assurer que les marins n'ont pas
avoir le scorbut
nous avons dit que vous savez apporter le zara
t-shirt rapidement car avec surement
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'amis
c'est bien mieux d'en avoir cent
pourcentage de la marine à base de fossiles
c'est beaucoup plus efficace et ça va
Plus vite
il y a quelques siècles nous avions 100 renouvelables
système de transport et nous nous sommes dit
tu sais nourrir
humiliation écologique pour le déjeuner ce n'est pas génial c'est
beaucoup mieux d'avoir 100
transport fossile ça marche mieux
nous avions 100 agricultures renouvelables mais nous
on s'est dit tu sais avoir un très
agriculture productive
et pour permettre aux enfants du fermier d'aller
étudier c'est pas génial c'est beaucoup mieux
avoir 100
l'agriculture fossile, nous avions 100
travaux publix renouvelables
c'est ce que les romains ont construit le romain
les routes avec ce n'était pas très rapide
faire un million de kilomètres de routes dans
france c'est beaucoup plus rapide d'utiliser un
machine comme ça
ça va beaucoup plus vite et on a eu 100
industrie de la construction renouvelable
essentiellement pour faire notre dame maintenant ce
va être un peu plus rapide à refaire
le toit mais je veux dire comme
et probablement quelques siècles pour faire le
pyramides ce n'était pas très efficace
faire la tour d2 la defense c'est beaucoup
mieux vaut utiliser les combustibles fossiles ça va beaucoup
plus rapide
nous avions à nouveau une industrie 100 renouvelables
n'était pas très efficace pour faire tout le
les articles que vous avez sur vous à petits prix
euh ouais ça n'a pas si bien fonctionné donc ça
était bien mieux d'avoir 100 fossiles
industrie
et nous avions 100 séchoirs renouvelables, c'est-à-dire
dire le soleil ce n'était pas très efficace
donc
mieux vaut brûler du gaz pour faire ça
va plus vite
donc ça fait deux siècles précisément
parce que les caractéristiques physiques de
les combustibles fossiles sont supérieurs aux
caractéristiques physiques des énergies renouvelables
quel homme qui est un animal cumulatif
a passé son temps à passer de
des énergies renouvelables aux énergies fossiles
pouvoir accumuler plus vite c'est
exactement pourquoi nous sommes descendus sur cette route
alors quand tu vois ça tu te rends compte que pour
aller dans l'autre sens
simplement parce que la promesse politique est
que nous allons y arriver
sans changer le niveau de vie des
personnes
rien qu'en voyant que tu te dis ah
sommes-nous totalement sûrs de cela
est-ce que je signe avec toutes mes économies plus celles
de mes parents plus mes grands-parents
sur le fait que ça va marcher
instantanément lorsque vous
avez des doutes sur quelque chose, c'est un
très bien
question à se poser mieux à dire
ce que j'accepte de parier tous mes parents
des économies sur ce que je déclare
et sont des performances si vous avez un
moindre doute sur le fait que
la réponse n'est pas oui
c'est qu'au fond tu n'es pas totalement
convaincu par les arguments ou par quoi
on te dit
donc les énergies renouvelables nous les connaissons très bien
c'est le monde d'où vient l'humanité
émerge et j'insiste
je ne dis pas que nous ne devrions pas revenir en arrière
là je te prépare juste à la
conclusion que nous n'irons certainement pas
là-bas
avec une consommation constante certainement
pas
pas avec 7 milliards d'hommes bons sur terre donc
ici ici vous avez nos convertisseurs d'ancien
fois c'était complètement immoral
et complètement inefficace tu vois
totalement inefficace
par contre c'était complètement
renouvelable et nous sommes maintenant passés à
convertisseurs modernes
qui sont sans doute beaucoup plus efficaces
sur ça
maintenant si je ne parle pas d'énergie mais
je parle de puissance tu vois ça
amen au travail
comme je vous l'ai dit plus tôt dans une journée de travail
nous pouvons faire entre zéro et
0,5 kilowattheure si vous divisez par le
cinq heures de travail
en fait ça devrait être 10 mais peu importe
tu vois ça veut dire qu'en moyenne
la puissance moyenne pendant cette dépense est
quelque part entre 10 et 100 watts
je prends un tracteur un tracteur ordinaire
a aujourd'hui une puissance de quelques dizaines de
kilowatts
un tracteur a la même puissance d'ailleurs
qu'une machine de construction qui a
une centaine de kilowatts
si un jour tu es un peu curieux
le temps que vous passez par le chantier de construction tous
les engins de chantier ont un peu
petite plaque qui a la puissance du moteur
c'est caché quelque part comme sous un
partie pivotante ou n'importe où
ce n'est pas très compliqué à localiser aller
cherche par curiosité tu verras
que la puissance de la machine se situe entre
quelques dizaines de kilowatts à 100 kilowatts
pour une grosse pelle
si vous substituez quelques centaines de jambes si
tu remplaces les armes par quelques milliers
donc les deux machines que vous avez ici sont
capable pour le tracteur de remplacer quelques
cent paires de pattes ou
quelques dizaines d'animaux de trait et les
engin de travaux publics ou la construction
machine quelques milliers de paires de bras
c'est grâce à cela que nous avons pu
augmenter la productivité d'un agriculteur
par quelques centaines
il n'a pas fait pousser des centaines de bras ou
des centaines de jambes comme shiva
le fermier qu'il était juste nous venons de lui donner
un exosquelette
et c'est grâce à cela qu'aujourd'hui nous
peut construire une maison
ça et tout un tas d'autres machines
comme les camions de cimenteries, etc.
nous pouvons construire aujourd'hui une maison pour le prix
de quelques années
de salaire quelque chose était totalement
impensable pour les habitants de l'ancienne
fois
jusqu'à il y a deux ou trois siècles, c'était
tout simplement impensable que quiconque puisse construire
sa maison pendant quelques années
salaire
il n'existait pas un camion qui [ __ ] comme un
quelques milliers de fois les jambes du conducteur
un avion grâce à un jeune et beau
pilote bien payé
pédales comme un million de fois les jambes de
un pilote l'aeroflot on doit pas avoir
colporté assez fort
un laminoir industriel
martèle ou écrase l'acier
comme toute la région parisienne
population à qui j'ai donné un marteau
donc vous voyez juste pour remplacer le roulement
moulin de fusion
si nous n'avions pas d'énergie tu le ferais
je n'écouterais pas ce cours
tout de suite
bien que certains d'entre vous soient peut-être mieux lotis
avec ça tu taperais sur du métal
feuilles avec un marteau
uniquement pour remplacer le mâle roulant de la
favoriser
toute la région parisienne avec un marteau
marteler toute la journée
ici vous avez un autre auxiliaire de
agriculture
qui a permis d'économiser quelques millions
des paires de bras ça s'appelle une vapeur
biscuit salé
et c'est quelque chose utilisé pour préparer
chimie organique
donc à ce stade
nous sommes d'accord sur le fait que l'énergie
quantifie la transformation
sur le fait que pour utiliser l'énergie
il nous faut un convertisseur
sur le fait que la plupart des convertisseurs
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui ne nous appartiennent plus
corps mais nos machines
maintenant je vais quantifier le parc machine et
comment
il est composé par la personne que je t'ai dit
historiquement
nous pouvons nous avons utilisé principalement des énergies renouvelables
énergies
ici vous avez un graphique qui commence dans
1860 et qui quantifie un seul des
énergies renouvelables que nous avons utilisées
dans les temps anciens parce que pour le vent et
l'eau était difficile à trouver
longue série chronologique de statistiques, j'en suis sûr
quelqu'un arrivera à le reconstituer
mais je n'ai pas réussi
donc ici on commence par du bois bois un
il y a un siècle et demi, l'humanité utilise
quelques
l'humanité l'utilise pour alimenter les poêles pour chauffer
eux-mêmes
ou éclabousser les forges et d'ailleurs le
début de la métallurgie a
été un facteur massif de déforestation
ou un facteur très important de
déforestation en europe
et faire fonctionner les premières machines à vapeur
qui commencent à émerger ici et là
donc à cette époque un habitant de la
monde un
terrien consomme en moyenne 5000
kilowattheures de bois par an
donc tu vois ça par personne depuis ça
temps la quantité de bois utilisée
a diminué
pas au total mais par personne il a
diminué
c'est la seule énergie qui a suivi
cette évolution
ensuite l'homme a commencé à utiliser le charbon
une partie du charbon a remplacé le bois pour
exemple en europe nous avons commencé à utiliser le charbon
mais avant nous étions
en utilisant du charbon de bois ou du charbon de bois, puis nous
commencé à utiliser le soi-disant tremblement de terre
les deux sont appelés charbon
exploiter des forges, puis exploiter
machines à vapeur
et vous voyez que la quantité de charbon utilisée
par personne dans le monde
qui était extrêmement petit un siècle et
il y a un demi s'élève maintenant à environ 5 000
kilowattheure par personne et par an
ce que vous voyez également sur ce graphique est
que la quantité de charbon utilisée par personne
dans le monde a
jamais descendu depuis que nous commençons à utiliser
charbon jamais
à tout moment cole a été une énergie de
le passé pour les hommes
jamais à aucun moment
en fait, vous utilisez aujourd'hui beaucoup sans le savoir
de charbon
à travers tout ce qui est importé de
pays où il se trouve
fabriqué en charbon en commençant par la chine
donc dès que vous voyez quelque part fabriqué en
la chine c'est
fabriqué en charbon et alimente directement votre
consommation
indirectement évidemment du charbon
les deux tiers du charbon que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
sur Terre
est en fait utilisé dans un intermédiaire
machine dans le système énergétique
appelée la centrale électrique
les deux tiers du charbon extrait sur terre
pouvoirs
une centrale électrique
dans le reste vous avez dix pour cent
environ qui alimente
métallurgie ce sont des appels spéciaux euh
très riche en carbone appelé
cokes le reste sert à
exploiter les réseaux de chaleur poêles
chauffage urbain je veux dire um domestique
chauffage etc.
mais les deux tiers sont l'énergie électrique
végétaux
tu sais qu'en france on a un gros
débat sur nos centrales nucléaires
rappelez-vous qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde vous
avoir entre 30 et 40 fois
entre 30 et 40 fois le nucléaire
puissance installée en france déployée
comme les centrales électriques au charbon
France nous avons
60 gigawatts d'énergie nucléaire, donc c'est
2 000 gigawatts de charbon
centrales électriques installées autour
le monde nous y reviendrons
pendant le cours climatique mais dans le
accord de paris au fait est-ce que
sonner une cloche à n'importe qui
bien l'objectif des deux degrés
contenant les accords de paris suppose
par exemple que
toutes ces centrales à charbon ont disparu
le moment où tu as mon âge
donc jusqu'à ce que tu aies mon âge ce qui n'est pas ça
loin je peux vous assurer
bien toute l'énergie électrique du charbon
plantes dans le monde
doit disparaître donc vous voyez qu'il y a un peu
de route à gauche
après les hommes ont utilisé de l'huile alors ce que vous pouvez
voir sur ce graphique d'une manière absolument
manière spectaculaire est que le pétrole n'a jamais
a remplacé le charbon
le pétrole n'a jamais remplacé le charbon vous voyez que
l'utilisation du pétrole
par personne est venu en plus de l'utilisation
de charbon par personne
la raison en est que l'huile ne
du tout ont les mêmes usages que le charbon
ou c'est l'énergie principale de la mobilité
parce que le pétrole est l'énergie qui a le
meilleur
rapport de l'énergie transportée par unité
volume
ok dans un litre donc un décimètre cube
si vous mettez quelque chose que vous utilisez pour
votre approvisionnement en énergie il n'y a rien
mieux que le pétrole
c'est liquide à température ambiante donc c'est
quelque chose qui est stocké
euh et transporté extrêmement facilement et
puisqu'il est le plus dense par unité
volume
dans les modes de transport où vous avez
emporter votre énergie avec vous afin que vous
pouvez être sûr d'aller où vous voulez
tous haut la main pour presque tous les modes
du transport
aujourd'hui 98 de quelles règles vole ou vente
utilise de l'huile
pendant que je vous rappelle que la première voiture à
ont dépassé les 100 kilomètres à l'heure en
le monde était électrique
je vous rappelle également que l'efficacité de
le moteur électrique est de trois à quatre
fois
l'efficacité du moteur à huile de sorte qu'il
n'est pas parce que le moteur à huile est
intrinsèquement supérieur mais il a
a remplacé le moteur électrique
dans le concours qui a eu lieu un
il y a un siècle, c'est parce que
avec l'électricité tu as beaucoup plus
peine à emporter avec soi l'énergie qui
permet d'être indépendant
c'est la raison
voir aussi quelque chose qui s'est passé avant
vous êtes né
ici l'arrêt soudain et je dis
soudaine de la quantité d'huile disponible
par personne sur terre
cet épisode a un nom assez particulier
dans l'histoire de l'énergie ça s'appelle
les chocs pétroliers j'y reviendrai à
longueur
les chocs pétroliers tout le monde s'en est souvenu
comme un moment où le prix
est devenu très haut et puis il est devenu très bas
encore et vous savez comme le sujet suivant
oublions ça en fait nous personne
a oublié
c'était le moment où l'approvisionnement en pétrole
augmentait fortement
et où il a cessé de croître fortement
alors que l'offre de pétrole par habitant était
en forte croissance et
non seulement il a cessé de croître fortement
mais il a
a également commencé à diminuer, puis
se stabiliser pour que les anciens amortisseurs ne soient pas juste
un épisode de prix
en fait c'est juste la mousse au niveau
surface d'une vague la majeure
caractéristique des chocs pétroliers
c'est que c'est c'est l'arrêt d'un rapide
monde en expansion
c'est le vieux choc et nous arriverons dans un
court instant
sur ce que cela signifie en termes économiques
puis vint le gaz
donc le gaz n'a pas remplacé le pétrole
il s'est rajouté dessus alors
vient l'hydroélectricité
de même l'hydroélectricité a été ajoutée
dessus de ça
vient ensuite le nucléaire qui a ajouté
a été ajouté en plus de cela
puis viennent les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
que vous voyez là et c'est
ce truc dont tout le monde parle nous
ne parle que de ça
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables
vous avez ici décrit par individu
quoi d'autre
les énergies nouvelles représentent dans le monde et
comme je suis malgré les apparences un gars sympa
j'ai pris la conversion la plus amicale
convention possible de les compter
car puisque la plupart de ces énergies sont
énergies purement électriques
donc solaire et éolien vous avez deux façons de
les comptabiliser dans
un bilan énergétique puisque historiquement
la majeure partie de l'électricité a été
produit avec des modes thermiques
Je veux dire que les centrales électriques sont charnelles
moteurs thermiques pour la plupart
vous brûlez du charbon ou du gaz ou du pétrole et/ou
uranium de fission
et ça crée de la chaleur et avec cette chaleur
vous exploitez une turbine qui est un
moteur thermique carnot et dans un carnot
moteur vous avez un rendement maximum
un moins t2 sur t1 et souvent
l'électricité est comptée dans le primaire
équivalent c'est-à-dire qu'on compte
l'énérgie thermique
qui aurait été nécessaire pour
produire la même quantité d'électricité
pour les modes purement électriques
l'hydroélectricité surtout quand solaire et
c'est la convention que j'ai utilisé
pour ce tableau
cependant aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui a
beaucoup plus
placer dans la pagination d'un journal
événement dans l'énergie effective
consommation dans le monde
et vous le verrez pas trop longtemps mais pas
c'est seulement vrai en valeur absolue mais
malheureusement c'est aussi vrai dans
dynamique d'autre part
une autre chose qui est capitale quand vous
regarde ce graphique
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui la quantité d'énergie
mobilisés par personne
par an énergie culturelle supplémentaire je devrais
clarifier
est de l'ordre de vingt mille
kilowattheures donc un terrien se mobilise
en moyenne à travers l'énorme
exosquelette qui constitue le parc
de machines vingt mille kilowatts
heures par personne et par an
avec les petits équivalents que je t'ai donné
plus tôt donc c'est dans
énergie primaire donc énergie thermique euh
donc l'énergie mécanique serait
moins évidemment mais vous remplacerez
jambes et bras
et ce que je vous dis, c'est qu'à peu près
Parlant
euh chaque terrien a à sa disposition
200 personnes
ou 200 esclaves qui travaillent pour lui du tout
temps
je vais vous dire d'une autre manière la flotte
de machines que nous avons construites qui fonctionnent
pour nous
a la même résistance mécanique que si
notre
la puissance musculaire a été multipliée par 200.
alors tu es moi nous sommes devenus superman
mais pour de vrai
ce n'est pas le fruit de l'imagination
sauf qu'au lieu de comme pape
se gaver d'une boîte d'épinards
et devenir super puissant nous bourrons
nous-mêmes avec un baril de pétrole et
devenir super puissant
ben pas nous mais notre exosquelette mais c'est
sauver les machines
je vais vous le redire d'une autre manière
production matérielle de l'humanité aujourd'hui à
7 milliards de personnes équivaut en volume
grâce aux machines à ce qu'on a quoi
nous aurions si nous étions
1 400 milliards de personnes et pas de machines
est-ce clair
évidemment nous n'avons pas les moyens de
nourrir 1400 milliards de personnes sur terre
donc en fait grâce à l'énergie et merci
aux machines que nous avons pu développer
une capacité de production qui dépasse
mesure par rapport à la puissance musculaire
de nôtre
organisme et nous passons nos journées à utiliser
prothèses
la ligne de métro d'erreur qui m'amène ici
est une prothèse
c'est une extension de mes jambes le tapis
vous pourriez utiliser encore plus dans l'avion
sont des prothèses vos extensions de notre
jambes nous passons notre temps à utiliser des prothèses
la plupart de cette énergie est fossile donc
pourquoi fossile tout simplement parce que c'est
vestiges de la vie ancienne
un fossile est encore très simple
il a une définition il est un reste de
ancien
la vie on verra ça dans le prochain cours
mais le charbon est un reste de
fougères de la vie végétale qui poussaient dans le charbon
ère du carbonifère
et pétrole et gaz ou restes de plancton
et des microalgues qui ont vécu
n'importe où entre quelques millions d'années
il y a et il y a quelques centaines de millions d'années
donc c'est de l'énergie fossile et de loin ça
domine l'offre mondiale actuelle
et cette énergie a permis de
mettre en mouvement un parc ou une culture
exosquelette
qui a fait de chacun
de toi iron man pour de vrai
nous sommes tous devenus iron man pour de vrai
nous n'avons pas une petite lumière brillante dans
le centre et des trucs devant le
yeux mais c'est exactement ça alors
voici des petits morceaux de ton iron man
machines à laver les costumes et les mines
ascenseurs aspirateurs
tracteurs tractopelles fusées aryennes
satellites purificateurs d'eau laminoirs
missions de tréfilage, etc. tout cela
sont des morceaux de votre costume d'homme de fer
et sans ce costume d'homme de fer tu
aurait la vie d'un paysan français
le même qu'il avait il y a quelques siècles avec
30 ans d'espérance de vie
à la naissance pas d'augmentation de salaire entre
naissance et mort l'idée d'un salaire
augmenter
avec l'âge euh c'est une idée moderne
ça n'existait pas autrefois et donc
et ainsi de suite
alors qu'est-ce qui a littéralement changé la vie
de l'humanité est l'énergie et la flotte de
machines qui nous permettent de l'utiliser
c'est pourquoi le fait que ça ne vaut que
trois pour cent de ce que nous dépensons est un
illusion d'optique, il est au centre de
cent pour cent de ce qui t'arrive
c'est 100 en fait avec le petit
convention économique que je vous ai montré
disant tout à l'heure que l'énergie aujourd'hui et
le parc de machines l'utilisant
est 200 fois la puissance musculaire de
humanité
si la comptabilité était en phase avec
cette réalité physique
dans les comptes des entreprises énergie
devrait valoir 200
fois plus que les salaires c'est ce que
devrait arriver
donc votre salaire de départ devrait être
à peu près euh
divisé par un facteur 1000 en gros
c'est à peu près ce que nous devrions faire euh si
nous voulions avoir la même comptabilité
relation
avec des coûts comme relation physique sur
la contribution
de la transformation du monde
je vais vous redire différemment parce que
j'y reviendrai dans peu de temps
les gens aujourd'hui pour la production ne sont que
nécessaire pour contrôler les machines
pour le reste sont fondamentalement inutiles pour
essentiellement tous les emplois que nous effectuons aujourd'hui dans le
monde je t'ai coupé les deux bras
jambes et vous permettent de contrôler un ordinateur
de ton cerveau
et ça marche toujours vraiment ça marche toujours
et donc cet exosquelette avec son
énergie caractéristique
il permet d'avoir la même productivité
capacité donc
pour la moyenne mondiale c'est un facteur de
200 mais en france la moyenne
ressemble plus à 600. donc le jaune français
gilet qui ne s'en rend même pas compte et
c'est l'indicible politique
réalité
vit comme un magnat il vit comme un
magnat ce qui le dérange c'est que le
le milliardaire français bernardo vit même
plus un magnat que lui
mais et il a probablement très raison de
pense que oui mais en attendant
il vit lui-même comme un magnat
à cause de cet exosquelette ces modernes
les esclaves en ont un autre absolument
avantage considérable par rapport à
énergies renouvelables des temps anciens
c'est qu'ils libèrent toute la surface pour
nous
parce que les esclaves énergétiques de l'ancien
fois les énergies renouvelables ou
d'autres organismes vivants celui que nous
besoin nous mobilisons la surface au sol
un animal de trait mobilise le sol pour que
sol nécessaire pour nourrir
l'animal de trait n'est plus disponible
pour nourrir des humains ou un animal de transport pour
cela importe
donc à l'époque on euh surtout dans
agriculture
nécessaires pour mobiliser une grande partie des
surfaces pour nourrir les animaux de trait
et pouvoir cultiver le reste de la
prestations pour hommes
les esclaves modérés mangent du sous-sol
donc ils laissent tout l'espace disponible
à nous
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
quand on parle de retourner à
énergies renouvelables
on voit apparaître des conflits d'usage des terres
par exemple pour faire pousser des cultures énergétiques
fins il vient
directement au conflit avec les cultures vivrières
ce qui signifie que
nous sommes contraints pour une partie de l'énergie
que nous utilisons pour retourner au sol
par rapport à l'avantage que nous avions de
pouvoir prendre du sous-sol
on revient donc à un bidimensionnel
système alors que nous avions réussi à
en allant
en trois dimensions d'une manière
quelques ordres de grandeur communs
consommation d'énergie
euh donc ce truc est très vieux donc le
commande mais les commandes ont quand même réussi
prise
il peut y avoir un facteur deux de diminution
pour certains d'entre eux mais ce n'est pas grave
la grande image
tout ce que vous voyez bien sûr euh je peux
traduire en
unités de jour d'esclave dont je me souvenais
regardant principalement ce graphique au plus de
la consommation d'énergie d'un occidental
donc les machines qu'il mobilise
pour
son propre avantage ce n'est pas l'ampoule
ni la tasse à café recyclable
donc dans ce contexte où je parle à
ingénieurs censés manipuler
ordres de grandeur
ce n'est pas avec de petits gestes que nous
éviter les gros problèmes
on peut avoir des petits gestes pour s'attaquer au
gros problèmes
mais cela ne remplace pas la nécessité de prendre
soin d'un gros problème
je te le dis parce que dans le monde je
vivre dans lequel est le monde de l'entreprise
il est encore très très courant que nous
confondre les ordres de grandeur
délibérément
nous nous cachons derrière notre petit air qui dit
c'est fabuleux j'ai mis une ruche sur le
toit
je mets des gobelets recyclables à la cantine toi
sais comme un jour par an les gens viennent
à vélo et
tu sais comme non non
ça ne marche pas comme ça évidemment ici
vous avez quelques ordres de grandeur sur
la consommation d'énergie
tu vois que ce qui va peser très très
lourd dans ce que nous
est ce que nous achetons et la façon dont nous nous déplaçons
et euh quand on parlera climat
change on verra ça
la façon dont nous mangeons est quelque chose d'important
et la façon dont nous étions logés
donc essentiellement la taille de la
logement que nous occupons
et l'énergie que nous utilisons pour l'occuper et
la quantité de choses que nous achetons dans l'année
ainsi que la façon dont nous nous déplaçons euh et le
nombre de kilomètres que nous parcourons dans le
année
ont bien plus d'impact que de désactiver
la lumière quand on sort de la chambre
ce sont des ordres totalement différents de
ordre de grandeur
en même temps que par personne car
jusqu'à présent j'ai parlé de quantités
par personne
où les ordres de grandeur ont
changé fondamentalement la taille d'un
la population a aussi fondamentalement
modifié
nous avons une reconstruction approximative
approximatif car bien sûr notre
l'agence nationale des statistiques était
dernière représentation il y a 10 000 ans
donc tu as une approximation
reconstruction de la population humaine
alors pourquoi il y a 10 000 ans
pourquoi ce graphique commence-t-il 10 000 ans
il y a
quelqu'un peut-il oui toi non non pas ça
oui c'est quand les hommes sont devenus sédentaires comme
dire qu'il y a dix mille ans
et nous verrons cela au cours
du changement climatique nous vivons nous terminons
la fin de la dernière période glaciaire
puis nous arrivons au début de la
phase interglaciaire chaude qui est celle
nous savions jusqu'à ce que nous commencions à mettre en
homme de mouvement
changement climatique d'origine humaine, c'est-à-dire
une période de stabilité
très forte stabilité à dire de la
climat qui permet aux hommes de devenir
sédentaire
mais c'est pour dire qu'avec une écurie
climat la ressource qui vous permet de
se nourrir n'est pas
vagabonde partout parce que ça bouge
selon climat ok
donc il reste toujours au même endroit et vous
peut commencer à devenir sédentaire
à cette époque l'homme était quelques millions sur
terre et je le répète insensé n'était pas
extrêmement efficace
à cette époque au début de la
révolution industrielle
donc je rappelle l'espérance de vie à la naissance
des habitants de la planète terre
euh en 1800 c'était
un peu moins de 30 ans et soit dit en passant
c'était inférieur dans les villes
qu'à la campagne parce qu'à cela
l'époque où la ville était un lieu de
concentration
de miasmes de toutes sortes donc dès que
vous aviez une maladie, il était beaucoup plus facile de
attraper et mourir de
c'est qu'à la campagne
avait aussi la même chose pour le bébé
mortalité
donc en 1800 on est un milliard et qu'est-ce que tu
voir
c'est que depuis deux siècles il y a
une évolution qui ressemble plus à une
hyperbole d'une exponentielle et au
en même temps
que la quantité de ressources de tous
type consommé par individu
a augmenté de sorte que certains des
les gens que je me connais inclus ont demandé
eux-mêmes à se demander si cela
démographique
l'évolution démographique aurait pu prendre
endroit sans le
une énergie abondante parce que si nous ne le faisions pas
avoir une énergie abondante, ce n'est pas
tout à fait sûr que la levure de céréales
serait passé de
10 à 80 quintaux par hectare dans le
région parisienne ce n'est pas complètement
sûr que nous aurions pu transporter le
la nourriture d'où elle pousse partout
c'est nécessaire
il n'est pas tout à fait sûr que nous le ferions
ont su le préserver contre
chaleur
froid ou petits animaux qui veulent manger
pour nous ce n'est pas tout à fait sûr que
nous aurions pu apporter
l'eau potable et évacué les miamis
des villes
et cetera donc il y a tout un tas de
des choses qui ne sont pas complètement
sûr dans un monde où nous n'avons pas
combustibles fossiles et il n'est donc pas
tout à fait sûr que nous aurions eu
sept à huit milliards de personnes
et si la question se pose de savoir si
sept ou huit milliards de personnes
n'est pas la conséquence de l'abondance
l'énergie en ce moment
évidemment la question corollaire qui
se pose est
à partir du moment où nous entrons dans une forte
récession énergétique
restons-nous huit milliards d'individus
et ce n'est pas tout à fait sûr non plus
si je fais la population multipliée par l'utilisation individuelle
c'est ce que j'ai au total
quantité d'énergie utilisée par l'homme
c'est-à-dire en gros le
évolution d'un parc machines
sachant qu'entre ici et là beaucoup
moins d'énergie est nécessaire pour faire fonctionner une machine
parce que
tes prédécesseurs et les miens étaient intelligents
sur le fonctionnement des machines
et donc avoir une inefficacité donc
ce que vous voyez il y a une limite inférieure
du parc de machines et d'exploitation
dans le monde
donc c'est probablement proche de la flotte de
machine ici
et il y a probablement plus près d'un dixième
d'un parc d'opérations d'usinage dans le
monde
euh ce que tu vois c'est qu'entre mon
la génération des parents et celle de mes enfants
génération
la quantité d'énergie utilisée par l'homme a
été multiplié par un petit facteur de
10. et à mon avis
avec l'efficacité énergétique qu'il y a
a été que
même période la flotte de
machines en fonctionnement le monde a été
multiplié par un facteur de quelques dixièmes
il n'est pas tout à fait certain que
entre vous et vos petits-enfants
génération la même chose se produit
il est en fait tout à fait certain que cela
ça n'arrivera pas
il est donc tout à fait certain que le monde
tu vas savoir et moi pour quelques
décennies
il me reste encore à vivre si tout va
bien ne sera pas un monde étendant le
tendance de ce que nous avions
dans le passé je te rappelle que physique
les systèmes sont rarement
systèmes linéaires en général ils sont
systèmes non linéaires
et dans les systèmes non linéaires, vous ne pouvez pas
raison par induction
il vaut mieux l'éviter
si je regarde la marque de l'homme sur son
environnement que je peux approximer
l'homme de markov sur son environnement par
quantité d'énergie qu'il apporte dans
jouer
puisque je répète la quantité d'énergie
que nous mettons en jeu
est le flux de transformation que nous
fonctionnent par définition de ce qu'est l'énergie
pour cela je prends l'énergie par personne
fois la population
et ça me donne quelque chose qui ressemble
l'évolution de la marque des hommes sur le
environnement
voila la population que je multiplie
par l'énergie utilisée par personne et ici
est en approximation du premier ordre
comment l'homme de markov sur son environnement
a évolué sur une planète qui était
13 000 kilomètres de diamètre à ce
le temps et c'est encore
13 000 kilomètres de diamètre maintenant donc vous
comprendre que l'environnement
problèmes que nous avons aujourd'hui
ne sont pas nécessairement des problèmes qui
qualifier de différentes manières
que ce que nous avions dans le passé sur le
d'autre part, ils quantifient dans différents
façons
par rapport à ce que nous avions dans le passé
nous avons aujourd'hui un tout petit problème de
ordres de grandeur
et quand tu vois ça toi aussi
comprendre que nous avons mis le système
un peu déséquilibré et c'est
pas tout à fait certain qu'il le fera
rester dans cet état pendant une période extrêmement
long
le temps où je te prépare
quelque chose que je détaillerai dans
d'autres cours qui est le fait que euh
que des choses désolées vont arriver
en tout cas à l'avenir
et en tout cas dans le futur le monde
ne restera pas stable
en tout cas et nous avons donc
tu as j'ai fondamentalement le choix
entre
j'attends que l'instabilité arrive comme
il veut arriver et je le supporte
ou je déclenche l'instabilité au sein du
les limites de ce que je peux ou
encore plus ou moins de contrôle mais ça va
être une
ou les deux autres
petits compliments sur l'évolution de
la quantité d'énergie utilisée dans le monde
tu as ici le
variation de la quantité d'énergie utilisée
par les humains
entre 2000 et 2017 ce que vous voyez est
que malgré le récit des médias
sur le fait que c'est vraiment bon
parce que nous sommes
nous avons de plus en plus d'éolien et de solaire
production que vous avez ici
les trois énergies qui ont augmenté
le plus durant cette période et de loin
sont les énergies fossiles gratuites et dans
charbon particulier
donc le combustible fossile qui a augmenté
le plus depuis que nous avons commencé
avoir de grands débats sur le climat, c'est du charbon
au cours de cette période, le charbon a augmenté davantage
que
10 fois plus que le primaire du comté solaire
équivalent
et plus de cinq fois plus que le
énergie éolienne
donc si le journal avait une pagination
reflétant les faits
pour un article ouais et à propos de solaire toi
devrait avoir 15
en parlant de charbon c'est ce qu'il faut
arriver et si vous regardez
aujourd'hui à ce que vous avez comme réserve
donc je fais le camembert du
évolution historique je vous ai montré
plus tôt
vous voyez que ce sont les combustibles fossiles qui
dominer l'offre mondiale de bout en bout
orteils
en première position le pétrole puis le charbon et le gaz
si je regarde juste les énergies renouvelables que vous voyez
que l'eau monte en premier c'est du bois
suivi de l'hydroélectricité je voudrais
vous faire remarquer que les deux premiers
termes d'un approvisionnement renouvelable de la france
sont les mêmes pour le bois et
l'hydroélectricité ce n'est pas parce que
nouveau
les journaux vous racontent à nouveau
éolien et solaire mais c'est tout ce qui compte
dans l'approvisionnement renouvelable français c'est
clairement du bois et de loin de l'hydroélectricité
les termes suivants sont beaucoup beaucoup plus bas
et donc voici le renouvelable français
fournir un petit graphique que j'ai fait non
plus tard qu'hier où les statistiques
sont publiés au plus tard le dernier
il y a une semaine ou deux semaines, ce que vous voyez est
ce
les deux premiers termes de loin d'un
l'inférence d'approvisionnement en énergie renouvelable sont
les bois
qui est principalement utilisé pour le chauffage et
l'hydroélectricité qui est
utilisé pour produire de l'électricité ici vous
avoir du vent et du soleil et
vous voyez que le solaire est en fait l'un des
termes les plus faibles du renouvelable français
fournir
derrière beaucoup de choses pompes à chaleur
incinération des déchets, etc. tout cela
énergies renouvelables
donc ici nous avons des millions de tonnes de pétrole
équivalent je t'avais dit que je viendrais
à tunnels équivalent en français
consommation qui s'élève à environ
à 250
de cette même unité afin que vous voyez ce que le
les énergies renouvelables représentent dans ce grand
image
d'accord, je vous donne à tous cinq minutes
pause assurez-vous de parler beaucoup pendant
ce temps
pas dans ma classe et comme seulement cinq
minutes pas 15.
merci beaucoup je reviendrai
le
les prix que vous avez probablement pour certains d'entre vous
entendu et j'y reviendrai ensuite
classe mais je vais faire un petit aperçu
aujourd'hui c'est le prix de l'énergie
euh qui j'espère n'est pas discuté
à l'arrière de
la classe
donc doit augmenter fortement si l'énergie
devient plus rare
ce qui a pour corollaire que plus
l'énergie abondante devrait voir son prix
fortement abaissé
en fait le prix de toutes les énergies est
plus ou moins subordonné au prix de
huile
ici vous avez le prix du pétrole exprimé
en monnaie constante c'est-à-dire
devise corrigée de l'inflation
pendant un siècle et demi tu vois
quelque chose d'assez intéressant le prix de
l'huile en fait
sur des tendances longues d'un siècle durant lequel
c'est
rigoureusement stable exprimée en constante
devise quelle que soit la quantité
produit
et vous voyez qu'au moment de votre
choc qui caractérise une forte
variation de la dérivée qui est
la production monte rapidement et s'arrête
augmente rapidement le prix augmente
brusquement puis revient plus ou moins
à son niveau précédent
vient alors un nouveau choc où le prix
augmente fortement puis revient à
quelque chose pas très très loin de son
niveau précédent
donc l'idée que le prix du pétrole est
quelque chose qui suit l'abondance de
l'offre
n'est pas confirmé par le graphique que vous voyez
là par contre
le prix réel des choses est en fait
un autre prix exprimé en argent
c'est un prix lié au seul
quantité qui reste
incompressible dans le temps qu'est le 24
heures d'une journée
autrement dit le prix réel de
rien n'est pas le prix exprimé dans
l'argent c'est pour le prix exprimé
dans les minutes de temps de travail si vous
vouloir exprimer
un prix en minutes de temps de travail vous
doit se rapporter
un prix à combien les gens gagnent donc vous
doit rapporter le prix de
pétrole dans ce cas à ce que les gens gagnent
c'est ce que vous voyez ici qui est le
pib par personne
à ce moment nous retombons sur nos pieds
tu vois ça dessus euh
le siècle dernier ou le siècle et demi
qui vient de passer
le prix du baril de pétrole était divisé
par
disons 15 à 20 ce qui veut dire qu'avec le
l'efficacité des machines qui a
augmenté
en même temps le prix du kilowatt
heure d'énergie mécanique
a été divisé par 50 à 100. nous trouvons
le même facteur de division que celui que nous
avoir quand on compare le prix de
une ancienne énergie renouvelable au prix de
une énergie fossile moderne
nous nous rabattrons toujours sur ce même
facteur de division ou facteur multiplicateur
de quelques dixièmes à 100 qui aussi
représente l'évolution d'un être humain
produire
avec ses armées et ses jambes au 200
équivalents d'esclaves par personne que nous avons
aujourd'hui
fondamentalement quelle que soit la direction de
que vous abordez le problème
le passage d'une civilisation renouvelable
à la civilisation fossile
a été l'apparition de surhomme et
homme de fer pour chacun de nous
avec une multiplication par un ordre de
grandeur entre
800 à plusieurs centaines de capacité
agir sur l'environnement
et bien sûr tout d'un coup tous les
indésirable
les sous-produits de cette capacité d'agir ont
également multiplié par plusieurs centaines
nous avons volé beaucoup de surface
d'autres êtres vivants c'est pourquoi il y a un
perte de biodiversité
nous avons induit beaucoup de pollution dans
l'environnement de toutes sortes donc il y a
tout un tas de substances que nous avons
ajouté à l'environnement
pendant que nous augmentons le
flux de transformation c'est un parfaitement
conséquence logique de cela
si l'on regarde une période plus récente sur
l'autre main tu vois
ici le prix de l'énergie par rapport à
ce que gagnent les français
vous voyez que les gilets jaunes peuvent être
raison et ont sûrement raison
pour leur cas particulier mais ils sont
mauvais pour l'ensemble de la population
puisque le prix de l'énergie par rapport à
ce que les gens gagnent en première approximation
n'a jamais été aussi bas qu'aujourd'hui
alors quand on dit ah le chef de tout ça
un an 50
d'accord sauf qu'on oublie que les gens
les fiches de paie ont augmenté en proportion
et même un peu plus vite j'ai déjà dit
c'est implicitement
et je le redis plus explicitement
cette énergie abondante vous permet d'être
assis ici aujourd'hui dans cette classe et
en général, il a radicalement changé la
monde qui nous entoure en ce qui concerne
travailler à des emplois presque toutes les personnes que vous
savoir
aujourd'hui travailler dans les services travailler dans le
les villes travaillent dans le secteur tertiaire
et je dis presque d'autres personnes que vous
savoir
c'est une situation très récente qui
la conséquence
de l'augmentation de l'approvisionnement énergétique vous
ai ici l'évolution du salariat
effectifs en france répartis en
agriculteurs en vert ouvriers en noir
et les travailleurs des services en bleu
ces trois courbes couvrent deux siècles
et j'ai ouvert une petite parenthèse
plus tu as de longues séries quand tu regardes
dans un processus
mieux tu es
la meilleure façon de mal interpréter un processus
est d'avoir une série de données trop
court
par rapport au temps caractéristique
échelles des variations
de ce que vous regardez, vous devez donc
ont
série un peu longue si vous voulez
comprendre quelque chose
ce que vous voyez c'est qu'il y a deux siècles
les deux tiers de la population active
travaillé dans
agriculture ils étaient pour les agriculteurs vous
peut
en déduire aussi quelque chose qui est que si
deux premiers
les populations actives sont sur le terrain
c'est parce que la productivité d'un agriculteur
à ce moment-là
est suffisant pour se nourrir plus la moitié
une personne qui fait autre chose
C'est ce que cela signifie
donc un agriculteur peut nourrir 1,5 personnes
et puis vous voyez que la main-d'œuvre dans
agriculture
puis augmente doucement augmente doucement
comme le volume de l'agriculture
production jusqu'en 1850.
Alors que se passe-t-il à ce moment-là ?
ne pas avoir
à l'heure actuelle toute augmentation significative de
productivité agricole
fondamentalement, un agriculteur de 1850 est aussi
productif en tant qu'agriculteur à partir de 1800 a
un peu plus mais pas beaucoup
d'autre part ce qui se passe
que la population augmente
et donc les forêts sont coupées à
augmenter
la zone cultivée dans laquelle nous dégelons
l'europe exactement comme nous déboisons
aujourd'hui en amérique latine et
ou en asie du sud-est et exactement comme nous
a fait à l'époque aux États-Unis et dans
la russie à tout moment la croissance démographique
a exigé des populations sédentaires
que l'on coupe des forêts pour les remplacer par
les zones cultivées c'est ce que
les européens font
et donc y compris les français et donc nous
couper les forêts
jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste plus grand chose à couper
c'est-à-dire qu'en 1850 nous avons traversé la
minimum de surface
15 de la france était couverte de forêts non
plus aujourd'hui c'est vingt-cinq
et les quinze pour cent couverts par
les forêts sont principalement des zones
compliqué à cultiver
montagnes notamment puis l'industrie
commence à développer des aides à l'agriculture
qui rendent l'agriculteur plus productif, nous
commencer
euh pour développer des brouillons de couleurs charrues et
cetera c'est le début de
fourrages dans l'industrie qui permet de
multiplier les auxiliaires de pour le
Les agriculteurs
la première moissonneuse-batteuse de mémoire
c'est la fin du 19ème siècle et
début du 20ème siècle et c'est
cheval tiré alors évidemment et ainsi
nous apportons à l'agriculteur des auxiliaires qui
permettent de réduire le nombre de
agriculteurs pour les remplacer par des machines ou
animaux de trait
dans les champs à ce stade évidemment
cela libère les bras pour que certaines personnes puissent
aller faire autre chose et qui nourrit
mais
non seulement la croissance de la main-d'œuvre
autres secteurs
et puis après la guerre alors où iron man
vient
pour de vrai, donc tu sais qu'Iron Man est un
création américaine dans les comics marvel
donc c'est vraiment l'américain depuis en
ce cas les américains
apporter les tracteurs et les engrais qui
ils commencent à se développer à la maison
et nous remplaçons la force de travail humaine et
animaux de trait par
beaucoup plus efficace que les tracteurs et
les engrais
en retour de ce que j'ai dit plus tôt mais
je vais répéter le rendement en série
dans les deux par exemple a été multiplié
de six à huit
entre 1945 et 1975 vous en connaissez six à
huit je ne sais pas si tu réalises
et à ce moment nous pouvons libérer beaucoup de
paires de bras et de jambes qui travaillent dans
l'agriculture pour les envoyer ailleurs
alors où est ailleurs bien on les envoie
dans l'industrie ou dans l'artisanat
qui est la même chose
dans l'industrie et l'artisanat nous sommes capables
grâce à l'augmentation de l'approvisionnement en énergie
mettre en mouvement et en nombre croissant
des machines
et chaque fois que j'ai une machine qui
démarre j'ai besoin de quelqu'un
pour le piloter j'ai une ligne de production de
voitures j'ai besoin de travailleurs qui travaillent sur la ligne
j'ai un marteau-piqueur j'ai besoin d'un ouvrier pour
améliorer un marteau-piqueur
j'ai une grue j'ai besoin de quelqu'un qui
fait fonctionner les grues donc nous construisons
de plus en plus
machines et il s'avère que
l'approvisionnement en énergie à ce moment-là, nous sommes au cours
les glorieuses années 30 donc
vous avez vu la vitesse à laquelle l'huile
par personne augmente l'approvisionnement énergétique
à ce moment-là augmente plus vite par personne
que le
taille unitaire d'une machine c'est un c'est un
course de chevaux
et donc malgré le fait que j'ai
machines de plus en plus grosses
je peux créer de plus en plus d'emplois parce que
le flux
les flottes de machines essentiellement
augmente
donc le nombre de machine augmente
parce que la taille de l'unité
de la machine croît moins vite
que l'approvisionnement en énergie par personne
donc je peux augmenter le nombre de machines
et ainsi augmenter le nombre d'emplois
dans l'industrie après les chocs pétroliers
l'inverse est vrai
la taille unitaire de la machine continue
augmenter
lorsque l'approvisionnement énergétique par habitant s'arrête
en augmentant
en ce moment j'ai besoin de moins en moins de monde
contrôler des machines qui sont d'ailleurs
de plus en plus
plus grand et qui continuera à
augmenter la production industrielle
la production industrielle en france a
doublé entre 1974 et 2007
donc après les vieux chocs on n'a pas
désindustrialiser on a fait une autre industrie
moins de stocks et plus d'avions
par contre ce qui s'est passé c'est que
la taille de l'unité
de la machine n'a cessé d'augmenter
alors même que l'approvisionnement énergétique par personne
il a cessé d'augmenter, nous avons donc
réduit les effectifs
dans l'industrie pour faire fonctionner des machines qui
sont individuellement plus grands
mais qui dans l'ensemble a produit plus mais
ici ce que je regarde c'est le nombre
des personnes non reproductrices
donc le nombre de personnes diminue et nous
ont également une deuxième catégorie d'emplois
qui augmente quels sont les emplois
inféodé à l'industrie donc ici aussi
quelque chose qu'il est très important de garder
à l'esprit
c'est que les emplois de service n'existent pas
sans flux physiques
un travail de service comme enseignant par exemple
si vous n'avez pas les flux physiques pour
faire un bâtiment
pour enseigner si vous n'avez pas
flux physiques pour amener les étudiants et
enseignants
sur place donc moyen de transport
si vous n'avez pas de flux physique à faire
matériel pédagogique
livres dans les temps anciens ordinateurs aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas de système d'éducation
un docteur
un médecin si vous n'avez pas les moyens de
fabriquer des médicaments
matériel médical à l'hôpital
équipement d'imagerie
l'hôpital lui-même et les moyens de
transport pour que tout fonctionne
vous n'avez pas de médecins si vous n'avez pas
une voiture fabriquée
vous n'avez pas le banquier à donner
les crédits auto
vous n'avez pas d'assureur pour assurer les voitures
tu n'as pas d'auto-école
instructeur pour apprendre
conduire et vous n'avez pas la police
agent pour vérifier que les gens sont
conduire correctement
tous ces emplois deviennent inutiles
bien qu'il s'agisse d'emplois de service
dans un monde où vous n'avez pas le
flux physique sous-jacent qui doit
fabriquer des voitures
donc une chose dont tu dois sortir
ta tête d'ailleurs je vais te montrer le
corrélations et pas trop longtemps
qui vous montrent que vous avez vraiment besoin de
sortez-le de votre tête qui est que
l'idée qu'un monde riche en services
l'emploi est un monde dématérialisé
c'est tout le contraire d'un monde riche en
les emplois de service est un monde dans lequel il y a
beaucoup de flux à gérer et c'est pourquoi
tu as besoin de beaucoup de monde pour t'occuper
il
donc les emplois de service augmentent à mesure que
production industrielle
augmente parce que nous devons continuer nous
devons gérer nous devons vendre nous devons
assurez-vous que nous devons enseigner, etc. et vous voyez
ici qu'il y a une période où le
les emplois de services continuent d'augmenter
parce que nous mettons
la production industrielle continue
augmentent alors même que les emplois industriels
commencer à décliner
d'autre part à partir de 2007 lorsque le
production industrielle
cessé d'augmenter en europe nous aussi
commencer à avoir le même sujet concernant
emplois de services
et vous voyez également une nouvelle catégorie qui
n'existait pas avant
au temps des vieux requins ils sont
les chômeurs
mais c'est dire que puisque l'énergie
l'offre par personne n'est plus
en augmentant
essentiellement donc la productivité du travail
augmente très peu depuis
augmenter la productivité du travail
signifie ajouter la productivité du travail des machines
augmente peu
et les emplois existants sont trop productifs
de sorte que
dans une économie qui a cessé de croître
rapidement, vous pouvez donner un emploi à tout le monde
en d'autres termes commencer les chocs pétroliers
nous entrons dans une époque où
la seule façon de donner un emploi à tout le monde est
diminuer
la productivité des personnes au travail et
donc l'équation est diverse
selon les pays certains ne le font pas
accepter et créer des chômeurs
amis d'autres acceptent et commencent à créer
des emplois qui sont
petits boulots mal payés et peu qualifiés
à temps partiel
etc ce sont pour les systèmes plus libéraux
les anglais allemands américains etc mais
c'est l'une des deux branches qui doit
prend place
c'est donc l'évolution dynamique de
france je vais maintenant vous en montrer plus
évolutions statiques et dynamiques qui
corroborer
ce que je viens de dire ici vous avez un graphique
dans lequel avec les données d'une banque mondiale
chaque point représente un pays
en abscisse la quantité et d'énergie
utilisé par personne qui est la flotte de
Machines
par personne en moyenne dans le pays et
sur l'axe des ordonnées, vous avez la fraction d'un
population active
ça marche dans l'agriculture tu vois c'est
très simple c'est
Dis-moi combien d'énergie tu as par
personne dans le pays et je te dirai
quelle est la fraction du travail
la population est dans l'agriculture
voir très simple et voilà
un autre graphique qui vous dira
c'est la même chose
l'évolution de 1991 à 2014
de deux données dans le monde alors voici le
moyenne mondiale
les émissions de vco2 par personne que vous avez
ici et la fraction des actifs
dans l'agriculture
ben tu vois que plus c'est un co2
augmentation des émissions, ce qui est le cas
lorsque vous suivez l'ordre chronologique
plus il y a de combustible fossile par
personne et moins vous avez d'agriculteurs
dans la population active donc c'est vrai
pour le monde dans son ensemble mais c'est aussi
vrai
par exemple pour l'inde seule ou pour
exemple pour la Chine
ou le brésil je veux dire j'ai 250 pays dans
la base de données je ne vais pas les jeter
tout à toi mais c'est quelque chose que tu
voir un peu partout
donc vous mettez de l'énergie dans un pays qui
signifie que vous mettez des machines dans le
pays
et les paysans dont vous les sortez
l'agriculture
c'est comme ça et donc tu crées
un exotique rural
c'est partout
en plus l'augmentation de l'agriculture
la productivité nous a permis de
augmenter le nombre d'animaux que nous
manger puisque nous avons besoin
plus de surface ou des surfaces plus productives
manger des animaux qui auront eux-mêmes besoin
manger ce qui pousse
80 % de ce qui pousse en france sert à
nourrir les animaux
c'est vrai pour les prairies c'est vrai pour
tout le maïs
à l'exception des quelques grains de marques qui
je ne nommerai pas et c'est vrai pour
la moitié du blé
c'est vrai pour presque tout le soja
cultivé dans le monde qui est l'un des
quatre gros grains que nous cultivons etc
environ 80 dans les pays occidentaux de
les surfaces cultivées servent à nourrir
les animaux que vous allez manger après
et ce que vous voyez ici donc ici je ne l'ai pas fait
vous donne l'énergie mais la serre
le gaz c'est n'importe quoi
ce que tu vois c'est que dans la serre
les émissions de gaz liées à l'alimentation
où est la viande ou le poisson la partie
liés aux énergies fossiles
est plus grand et ce que vous voyez est que le
sens de l'histoire en raison de la
augmentation de l'approvisionnement en énergie
est d'aller de gauche à droite historiquement
nous avons mangé
céréales et oignons c'est pourquoi le
les paysans supportent mal
donc des céréales et des oignons puis on a commencé à
manger de petits animaux
oeufs bien premier produit de petits animaux
œufs
et puis les petits animaux eux-mêmes
rappelez-vous le hareng avant que les gens doivent être
capable de manger de petits animaux le poulet
pot
mais c'était déjà une perte de main
parce qu'elle avait donné toute sa vie et
tu as un
fin de vie gaspiller la poule qu'on a mangé
puis nous avons commencé à manger
poulet bouilli puis nous avons commencé à manger
cochons quand on a commencé à manger des vaches
et pouvoir élever des vaches juste pour manger
eux c'est quelque chose
c'est l'emblème d'un pays
subissant une infusion d'énergie
ça ne marche pas et l'archétype est le
États-Unis
ça ne marche pas dans un pays avec un faible
réserve d'énergie
et en raison de la productivité apportée
par les machines cela de plus en plus
les régimes à base de viande nous coûtent de moins en moins cher
ici vous avez une part de nourriture dans le
budget des ménages aux états-unis
donc c'est une longue série et j'ai pris le
états-unis parce que c'est facile à trouver
longue série sur les sites américains
malgré le génie des français
ingénieurs trouvant de longues séries de cela
nature et en clics de souris gratuits sur le
les sites français sont très difficiles
et je ne sais pas pourquoi donc de toute façon ça marche
très bien aux états-unis
donc aux états-unis tu vois que euh un petit
il y a un siècle
le budget alimentaire des ménages est un
quart de ce qu'ils gagnent
et à l'époque c'était essentiellement la maison
traiteur donc mme mishu et
désolé pour le commentaire sexiste mais c'était
la réalité achète des produits bruts au
paysan local ou à la place
du marché local et fait sa première
thé pour monsieur misho et elle-même
de euh lieues de pommes de terre
à partir d'œufs et de poulet
aujourd'hui quand tu vas acheter de la nourriture
en fait la majorité de ce que vous achetez 80
des achats alimentaires d'un français
passe par les supermarchés et les
la majeure partie de ce que vous achetez n'est pas de la nourriture
le ticket de caisse à la sortie du supermarché
ce sont les salaires des caissiers
ou les salaires des ingénieurs du
entreprise qui a fait le
terminaux de paiement automatique non
matière
c'est euh c'est un espace de location
c'est un salaire de magasinier
c'est le salaire du transporteur c'est volvo
revenus des camions
c'est un chiffre d'affaires de publiciste et cetera c'est
tout sauf de la nourriture
quand vous regardez les produits bruts et
ce que vous achetez dans les bons cas c'est un
tiers de l'argent
dans les mauvais, c'est trois pour cent de prise
l'exemple d'une boite d'oeufs
combien coute une boite d'oeufs en
les supermarchés
les méchants pas les bio
non non c'est les bio qui coûtent
pour euros
ouais exactement 150 1,5 euros
à peu près donc un euro 50 pour six œufs
Et puisque tu es plus fort que moi dans
calcul mental qui met l'œuf à
oh c'est dur oh quinze divisé par
six
combien coûte ce pisse de viagra
15 cents 25 cents nous sommes d'accord là-dessus
alors savez-vous combien coûte le même œuf
acheté à la ferme
pas mal du tout c'est pas loin de cinq
c'est six à sept centimes
donc vous voyez que juste sur une boîte d'œufs
sans aucun traitement
comme aucun traitement du tout, vous avez un
facteur de quatre
entre ce qui sort de la ferme et ce que vous
payer à la caisse donc j'insiste
le reçu aujourd'hui est tout sauf de la nourriture
ce qui signifie que lorsque vous faites
une longue série vous avez en fait un
massif en homogénéité
entre ce que vous observez au début de
une série et ce que vous observez à la fin
de la série
parce qu'au début d'une série c'est
vraiment l'œuf à la sortie d'une ferme mais
au marché par mme michoud aujourd'hui
c'est pas du tout ça
et en fait si tu regardes euh en fait
en dehors de la maison c'est encore pire
l'omelette au café du coin vous ne serez pas
payez un an ou 50 vous payez
comme cinq ou six euros et pour des œufs gratuits
donc c'est au moins 75 cents par œuf
donc vous pouvez ajouter un facteur de 10. donc
en fait, le prix réel de la nourriture aujourd'hui a
à peu près divisé par un
facteur de 20 sur cette échelle de temps
donc le reste c'est du service et on tombe
encore une fois sur ce facteur de division
de quelques dizaines
cela varie selon le produit
grâce à l'abondance d'énergie
cette abondance d'énergie a également apporté
nous le moyen de transport
garder à l'esprit sans entrer dans
détails que plus un moyen de
le transport est moderne plus son
la consommation au kilomètre est élevée
donc nous avions des vélos donc nous avions à pied nous avions
faire du vélo nous avions le bus nous avions le train
etcetera et aujourd'hui nous avons l'avion
qui est le plus
mode énergivore de
transport par personne de volvo vous pouvez
imaginer
une fois que nous avons eu ces extrêmement efficaces
moyens de transports
euh on a aussi pris
l'occasion de faire autre chose alors
juste une petite remarque
dans les homogénéités et séries longues
tu as autre chose à voir
c'est-à-dire qu'avec le temps certains objets
ne peut plus être affecté uniquement
euh leur fonction d'origine car une voiture
aujourd'hui
n'est pas qu'un moyen de transport c'est
aussi un salon sur roulettes
c'est votre propre espace que vous transportez
à la porte du bureau et que
est aussi quelque chose qui a de la valeur et
c'est aussi un objet de statut social
donc je fais une petite parenthèse ici
sur l'inhomogénéité des séries
une voiture quand on la compare à quelque chose
sinon parfois c'est dur de savoir à quoi
voici le dernier avatar de la voiture ce
est la voiture autonome d'ikea
est-ce une voiture est-ce un salon
roues
est-ce un ordinateur sur roues qui
vous transporte instantanément
comme c'est quoi cette chose la
voiture autonome connectée alors ouais
donc de temps en temps tu as aussi toi
présentent également des inhomogénéités
à laquelle euh ouais avec laquelle tu dois
faire attention
revenir au premier objet qui
est de déménager
non les moyens plus ils sont modernes
plus ils consomment au kilomètre
non non ce que je dis c'est que la voiture
consomme plus que l'avion qui est un
des moyens plus modernes
et la oh pardon la voiture consomme moins
que l'avion et l'avion est plus
moderne
et la voiture consomme plus que le train
ce qui est plus ancien et ainsi de suite et
tu en sais ouais plus que le bus et le
le bus lui-même consomme plus que le vélo
qui est plus ancien
et cetera fondamentalement le plus moderne
les amines est
plus sa consommation au kilomètre
est haut
et en fait c'est ce que je représente
ici
ce que vous avez ici est un graphique qui
vous donne la quantité d'énergie utilisée dans
euh
équivalent d'huile gramique et donc d'ailleurs
pour
voiture de bus et avion c'est vraiment du pétrole et
donc par passager-kilomètre c'est ça
vous avez ici
et donc tu vois qu'avec le temps ça monte
j'avais l'habitude de dire qu'il est inférieur pour le
train avec un bus
plus bas pour le bus quand pour la voiture et
plus bas pour le carbone pour l'avion
et ainsi de suite sur l'axe des abscisses vous avez un nombre
de passagers-kilomètres parcourus
dans l'année donc la région vous donne le
quantité d'énergie allouée à chaque mode
du transport
et donc tu comprends que la route
domine aujourd'hui
les transports que nous effectuons
et donc je répète que le sens de l'histoire est
passer des moyens économiques aux
des moyens moins économiques car il y avait
de plus en plus
énergie disponible par personne qui dans ce
la chambre n'a jamais
pris l'avion
deux ai-je bien compté
c'est vrai j'aurais demandé la même chose
question en 1950 j'aurais dû poser
c'est l'inverse
mais c'est pour dire qui a qui dans cette pièce
a déjà pris l'avion
Et je verrai probablement deux mains se lever
l'avion aujourd'hui dans vos réseaux sociaux
catégorie professionnelle
et dans votre pays est quelque chose que nous utilisons
comme nous respirons
c'est hyper récent et d'ailleurs
quand tu as mon âge ce n'est pas tout à fait
sûr que ce sera toujours le cas
est extrêmement récent
parce que c'est quelque chose qui demande
de très très grandes quantités d'énergie
rappelez-vous qu'un tour de paris new york
voyage c'est un très très grand bain
c'est 400 à 500 litres d'huile par
personne pour un voyage
c'est-à-dire à peu près la même chose que
conception annuelle de quelqu'un qui utilise
leur voiture
pour un voyage
c'est beaucoup n'est-ce pas donc l'ouverture
de l'équateur signifie
à l'étranger excusez-moi euh
je dois vivre avec mon temps en 2016 c'est
pas complètement exclu mais il semble
plus comme des trains de nuit vers la suède
qu'un avion pour aller à kuala lumpur ou
Chine
Ou peut-être reviendrez-vous en bateau à moitié
énergie éolienne pour aller en chine
ça te prendra un mois mais ça partira
vous avec beaucoup de bons souvenirs
ici vous voyez comment les gens se déplacent sur un
siècle et demi
désolé plus de deux siècles que vous avez
sur une échelle logarithmique ici le nombre
de
kilomètres parcourus par personne et par jour
selon les différents moyens de
transport
alors vous voyez que le cheval ce qui était quoi
a donné le plus
personnes-kilomètres par jour après avoir marché
qui est ici en blanc
et il y a deux siècles donc deux siècles
il y a environ
le voyage quotidien d'un être humain était
trois kilomètres à pied
qui use les chaussures car deux
il ya des siècles
comme vous l'avez vu plus tôt l'humain ordinaire
être était un paysan
qui a donc fait des allers-retours
entre la ferme et les différents lieux
où il devait aller pour faire son travail
ses champs ses vergers ses prairies etc
c'est ce qu'il faisait tout le troisième jour
kilomètres
et à part ça il a vécu toute sa vie
la vie sans aller quelques centaines
kilomètres de là
c'est vrai alors tu vois
le cheval puis voici la montée du
former
et surtout l'essor de la voiture
ici qui est devenu le mode dominant
des transports aujourd'hui
mais l'année où la voiture a supplanté
la marche comme moyen de transport dominant
en termes de passagers-kilomètres par jour
c'était les années 1950
donc je ne suis pas né mais à peine mes parents
sont nés et bien nés
donc mes parents qui sont déjà nés à
ce temps
sont nés dans un monde où les
mode de transport dominant
pour l'ensemble de la population était
marcher je ne sais pas si tu
comprendre aussi ce que cela signifie dans
rapport au monde
vous vivez dans
nous avons augmenté je veux dire que nous avons
diminué
le nombre de paysans et comme je l'ai dit
plus tôt nous avons mis ces paysans quelque part
alors où faites-vous commodément l'industrie
puis des emplois tertiaires
dans les villes historiquement quel est le
la ville c'est un lieu d'échange
quand vous regardez les villes qui étaient
construits il y a longtemps, ils étaient tous
organisé
autour des lieux d'échanges qui sont
le marché où j'échange des marchandises
un lieu de culte où j'échange
croyances et règles morales
le et donc l'église pour parler de la france
est toujours au centre
d'une mairie ou équivalent qui doit
dire que nous échangeons des règles de vie
ensemble
à l'école où j'échange des connaissances afin
les lieux d'échange sont au centre et
géométriquement la chose la plus efficace
est un disque
avec tout le monde autour c'est ce que le
la forme la plus compacte est le disque est le
forme la plus compacte
autour des lieux d'échange qui sont
le tout placé au centre
une fois que vous développez l'abondance signifie
produire dans le transport alors deux phénomènes
arrivera
un tu videras les zones rurales deux
vous allez mettre les gens qui sont les
le plus efficace pour
premièrement produire et deuxièmement échanger
production et où est-elle la plus
efficace pour produire un échange
production
dans les villes c'est dans les villes que
c'est le plus efficace
pour faire ça donc tu vas mettre le
les gens dans les villes
et en augmentant l'énergie qui est
d'où je viens
vous augmentez la part de la population
qui vit dans les villes
donc c'est comme ça que ça se passe pour un monde comme
un tout en 1960 vous aviez 30 ou
un peu plus de 30 % d'une population vivant
dans les villes avec trois tonnes de co2 par
personne qui représente le combustible fossile
que nous utilisons
c'est-à-dire toute l'énergie que nous utilisons dans
première approximation et vous voyez que
aujourd'hui nous sommes à cinq tonnes donc nous avons
augmenté l'énergie
et cela nous a permis de mettre la moitié du
désolé les deux tiers de la population de
les villes
donc cette évolution peut être vue à un
rythme axillaire accéléré dans le
pays qui ont connu une accélération
accès à l'énergie oui question
oui il y a un lien de causalité
parce que vous déformez la structure
des emplois
et parce qu'un système dans lequel vous avez
laissé tous les artisans chacun dans leur
coin avec transport intermédiaire
c'est beaucoup moins efficace que tout
système dans lequel vous mettez 100 artisans
ensemble
qu'on appelle alors ouvriers d'usine
et dans un endroit où tu vas
se spécialiser dans la production
qu'il deviendra beaucoup plus efficace
je vais vous dire d'une autre façon de faire
voitures
si vous avez le boulon 12 qui est fabriqué en
bref et le décor dans la porte qui
est fabriqué en orijak
et le bout de la porte qui est fait en
baldo tu ne peux pas gérer tout ça
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile de tout mettre
ensemble au même endroit
et ont des opérations qui sont assemblées
au même endroit
après quand les transferts deviennent de plus en plus
plus accessible vous pouvez
même aller plus loin et hyper-spécialiser
certaines opérations sur certains sites
puisque le transport ne vous coûte rien et
puis emmenez-les à
d'autres endroits où en grande partie vous hyper
spécialiser
dans autre chose et c'est pourquoi pour
exemple un fabricant
assemble des cabines de camions ailleurs
que là où il les peint
et entre les deux tu portes non peint
cabines de camion
donc tu as exactement la même évolution
à observer pour la chine
idem pour le brésil idem pour
thaïlande le semper indonésie etc
donc plus d'énergie je le répète ça déforme le
structure de l'emploi dans la mesure où
je vous ai mentionné plus tôt
et les emplois qui apparaissent sont les plus
efficace lorsque vous augmentez la taille de
les villes
donc vous pouvez augmenter la taille des villes
tout en les enjambant
et c'est aussi exactement ce qui se passe
quand vous avez accès à une énergie abondante
car en ce moment emménager
les modes mécanisés deviennent
facile et donc vous essayez de faire le
le meilleur des deux mondes
c'est à dire un peu d'espace autour
tout le monde tout en ayant extrêmement
flux de traits importants
et pour cela vous ne pouvez réussir que si vous
avoir beaucoup d'énergie
donc dans la ville basse énergie le plus
chose compacte qu'il y a est le
bâtiments typiques de la manie de la maison persane
Paris est l'une des villes les plus denses de
le monde malgré l'absence de
très hautes tours
parce que quand vous avez de très hautes tours
tu commences à devoir partir un peu
espace autour de chaque tour
c'est compliqué de serrer le tout
hautes tours que vous serrez la maison
principalement des bâtiments
qui sont tous collés je veux dire
il n'y a pas d'espace entre les bâtiments
ils descendent tous dans la rue mais ils sont
le tout collé avec 10 ou 30 étages
bâtiments
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de faire ça
et en plus c'est le moyen le plus efficace
quand vous n'avez pas assez d'énergie pour
se déplacer
parce que vous pouvez tout faire à pied ou
si nécessaire sur charrette à cheval
Et quand tu donnes une voiture à tout le monde
tu viens de faire los angeles
où tu gardes l'échange urbain
fonctions tout en pouvant
mettre la ville à 100 ou 150 kilomètres
en diamètre
où chaque personne a une voiture et vous gardez
les mêmes distances parcourues en une heure dans
une ville considérablement plus étendue
planification
c'est la raison pour laquelle quand vous regardez
par exemple la région parisienne
c'est la distance entre la maison
et un travail représentatif de la
euh
de euh désolé qui est représentatif de
le
échanges quotidiens en 1975 alors où en est-il
pourquoi c'est euh c'est là que nous ne le faisons pas
beaucoup voyager
donc en 1975 voici une ville dense
les gens vont au travail à pied et ici 80
kilomètres de là, vous êtes toujours dans le
la campagne et les gens
marcher jusqu'à leurs champs bien et cela
c'est comme ça qu'il évolue dans le temps
et c'est là que nous en sommes au début
2000 tous ces gens
sont devenus urbains périurbains
dont le métier est devenu un urbain
type de profession afin qu'ils ne soient plus
Les agriculteurs
ce sont des travailleurs de l'industrie
travailleurs et nous sommes donc entrés dans le
système de mouvement
nécessaire à l'industrie et
services et ils utilisent leur voiture parce
ici il n'y a pas
transports en commun et il n'y aura jamais
et donc vous commencez à avoir extrêmement longtemps
distances entre le domicile et le travail
et au fait c'est ici que nous en sommes
projet de mettre le métro du grand paris
dans un rayon de 20 kilomètres, il
ne résout absolument pas les problèmes pour
ceux qui habitent loin
loin cette énergie d'abondance a également fait
possible d'augmenter le nombre de
boîtiers
et cela lui a permis de grandir plus vite
que la population
en 1978 ou disons à l'époque pendant
de vrais chocs
le logement moyen en france était
77 mètres carrés et tu avais
un peu moins de trois personnes à l'intérieur
il aujourd'hui vous avez un peu plus de deux
les gens à l'intérieur
lui et le logement lui-même a
grossi
donc évidemment c'est l'énergie qui a fait
c'est possible de faire ça
donc l'énergie a notamment fait divorcer
possible
car pour divorcer il faut
avoir deux maisons là où tu n'en avais qu'une
avant
sinon ça ne s'appelle pas un divorce c'est
appelée perle de ménage
ou ce que tu veux mais ça ne s'appelle pas
divorce
un divorce est une séparation physique que vous
besoin d'avoir un moyen de loger les gens
et d'ailleurs aujourd'hui l'un des facteurs
de pression à la hausse sur les besoins en logement
en France
nos divorces est probablement le premier
facteur de pression à la hausse
vous trouvez ce que je viens de vous dire ici dans
ce petit graphique
qui vous donne ce temps pour une donnée
année les émissions de co2 par
personne selon la part de
emploi
dans les services et vous voyez que ce graphique
dit tout
sauf le fait que lorsque vous augmentez
emplois dans les services
proportionnellement les émissions le diminuent
vous dit tout sauf que
c'est la seule chose que tu ne peux pas
voir dans ce graphique
alors voici une autre façon de voir cela
cette fois dynamiquement pour le monde en tant que
ensemble
encore une fois vous avez la part des emplois et
services en 1991 et en 2014
avec les émissions de co2 par personne que vous
voir qu'ils
marchent ensemble et qu'ils marchent aussi
ensemble quand vous regardez des pays pris
un par un ça marche très bien
un autre développement que l'abondance
l'énergie a permis est l'augmentation de
flux de marchandises
puisqu'il s'applique également aux camions ici
il y a aussi quelque chose que tu dois
sortez de votre cerveau qui est que vous
pourrait dématérialiser le transport en
le remplacer par des flux d'informations
apparemment ce n'est pas vrai quand vous
voir l'évolution simultanée de
flux d'information et de transport, qu'il s'agisse
ce sont des biens de personnes d'ailleurs
vous avez exactement les mêmes résultats que
deux évoluent ensemble
donc aujourd'hui à l'échelle macroscopique pour dire
que faire circuler plus d'informations
nous permettre de faire circuler moins de monde ou
moins de marchandises, c'est mal
ce n'est tout simplement pas comme ça que ça marche après nous
pouvons nous poser la question
pourquoi ça ne marche pas comme ça mais le
résultat brut est qu'il ne suffit pas de
augmenter la quantité d'informations
circuler pour dire
bam le résultat est que moins de gens sont
se déplacent ou moins de marchandises se déplacent
a donc restructuré le pays
ce que je vous présente pour les amis
a été appliqué dans tous les pays qui
avait accès à l'énergie
vous les aviez tous peuplés
campagne
et les villes pas trop grandes tu as déménagé beaucoup
grandes villes
et des campagnes et des villes vides
étalé
tous les pays qui ont suivi la même
s'orienter
les seuls pays qui ne l'ont pas suivi
sont ceux qui ont eu des obstacles géographiques
qui s'est opposé à cette évolution
je vais vous donner un exemple suisse
la suisse a en effet
a augmenté ses villes, mais ils n'ont pas
épeler trop
pourquoi parce que quand tu as une ville au
fond d'une vallée
étendre la ville, c'est grimper sur le
les flancs et c'est compliqué
ils l'ont fait un peu en mettant des chattes a
un peu partout mais ils ne l'ont pas fait
de manière massive en particulier ils
n'a pas mis de supermarchés en périphérie
de la ville parce que
mettre les supermarchés en terrasse sur
le haut de la ville c'est plus
compliqué que de le mettre sur le
faubourgs
encore une fois les pays qui n'ont pas
suivi cette évolution c'est parce que
ils avaient une barrière physique qui
les a empêchés de le faire
l'énergie abondante s'est également appliquée à
loisirs
tout d'abord les loisirs ont augmenté
parce que
les machines produisent pour nous et cela nous libère
temps de disponibilité
ça fige le temps des études et les journées
où il n'y avait pas de machine
il n'y a pas eu de longues études ça libère
l'heure de la retraite à l'époque
où il n'y avait pas d'énergie abondante
il n'y avait pas de retraite
ça fige le temps des vacances
il fige le temps de ne rien faire sur le
les week-ends et ça fige le temps
travailler seulement 35 heures par semaine tout ça
temps libre
que nous avons gagné, nous le devons tous au
énergie abondante
ici pour se souvenir de quelque chose qui va
s'appliquent non seulement à vous mais
aux personnes avec qui vous travaillerez et
vivre avec pour le reste de votre vie
dans un monde où l'énergie est limitée, c'est
pas l'augmentation du temps libre
bien géré disons que ça s'appliquera
ce que vous voyez ici est l'un des
occupations de temps libre appelées
tourisme donc j'ai fait un peu de maths
il y a quelques années je n'ai pas refait le
calcul mais l'ordre de grandeur
est toujours le même
et il vous donne les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre donc à nouveau le
consommation d'énergie fossile
lié à la façon dont nous passons nos vacances
ici j'ai compté le voyage initial le fait
d'aller à votre
lieu de vacances en train voiture ou avion i
compté la fabrication éventuelle du
objet dans lequel vous vivez pendant
la résidence secondaire je considère que
s'il a été construit je l'ai compté
et si c'était euh de l'ancien
belle-mère que nous devons endurer
nous n'avons rien compté parce qu'elle l'avait
maison déjà construite il y a longtemps
et j'ai aussi pris en compte local
voyages tous les et cetera
si ce sont les vacances au ski que j'ai prises
compte le chauffage de l'appartement
car en général le ski c'est compliqué
quand il fait un peu chaud
il fait un peu froid et donc le
les appartements sont chauffés de préférence avec
essence
et ainsi de suite donc j'ai pris en compte tout
cette chose
et ce que vous voyez, c'est que le plus moderne
forme de tourisme
celui-ci je pars en voyage de trois jours
à un hôtel en prenant l'avion
est aussi celui qui assume la
plus grande quantité d'énergie consommée
s'offrir une semaine de vacances à l'inverse
ceci et cela qui sont les formes de
loisirs apparus avec
congés payés c'est-à-dire que les personnes
pris leurs vélos pour aller au camping ou
pris le train pour aller camper c'est quoi
ils l'ont fait au début des congés payés
et ce sont les énergies les plus fossiles
des formes efficaces et donc de l'énergie
formes efficaces pour exercer
vous voyez à nouveau cette abondance d'énergie
a déformé nos modes de vie
et nous devons les faits de pouvoir
avantage
de cette offre de loisirs
au fait que nous sommes sous énergie
perfusion nous tous autant que nous sommes
c'est pourquoi se développe actuellement dans
la suède par exemple depuis quelques années
et nous en avons parlé dans le
médias pendant quelques semaines, mais
en fait, quand vous regardez les statistiques,
commencé il y a quelques années
un début de diminution du nombre
d'avions pris par les suédois
qui est maintenant décrite par les médias comme
honte de voler
parce que les scandinaves ont un peu plus
sensibilité environnementale développée
que le reste des européens qui peuvent être
expliqué pour historique et
raisons géographiques
on trouvera ça économiquement
avec ce qu'il en coûte exprimé en heures de
temps de travail
pour prendre l'avion je te le redis
le vrai prix des choses ce sont les heures de
temps de travail
et ce que vous voyez, c'est que le prix
exprimée en heures de travail
prendre l'avion était divisé par un
facteur extrêmement grand
d'ici quelques décennies
c'est une autre façon de dire que
l'énergie est devenue plus abondante
dire que c'est
plus facile d'acheter beaucoup avec une heure de travail
c'est la même chose
l'énergie alimente aussi les machines industrielles
et des machines industrielles seront utilisées pour
faire tous les objets qui vous entourent
aujourd'hui
donc les tables sur lesquelles tu t'appuies
pour certains
mûrit dans lequel vous êtes assis pour tous
les vêtements que tu portes
les lunettes pour certaines chaussures, etc.
[Musique]
tout a été fabriqué par des machines industrielles
donc l'énergie alimente les machines industrielles
c'est l'exosquelette qui permet de faire
tout
y compris les ciseaux cosmétiques et euh
et films netflix
mais il sert aussi de matière première donc
vous avez une énergie un composant qui est
parfois appelé non énergique
et tu pourrais me dire le
l'énergie énergétique c'est un peu compliqué
mais en fait quand tu vois non énergique
usages de l'énergie
en particulier dans le pétrole et le gaz, il sert de
matières premières pour la chimie organique
toute la chimie organique est basée sur
dérivés du gaz et du pétrole
ici les américains ont eu un petit test amusant
ils ont sorti d'une maison
tous les produits qui contiennent de l'huile
dérivés
et rien ne reste en fait ils devraient
ont également éteint les planchers parce que
il y a du cirage sur les sols ils devraient
ont éteint les rideaux qu'ils devraient
ont éteint le rideau
tige ils auraient dû enlever la peinture je
signifie fondamentalement que nous aurions dû supprimer
tout le pétrole aujourd'hui n'est pas seulement
quelque chose qui fait tourner la machine
c'est aussi la base du bio
la chimie pour fabriquer la totalité
de produits qui nous entourent parce que vous
n'es-tu pas à peu près
n'ont pas un seul produit qui
vous entoure dans lequel vous n'avez pas de
dérivé
de pétrole
ces objets qui nous entourent nous allons
avoir à les faire et d'ailleurs certains de
ils utiliseront également de l'énergie
ici vous avez par exemple l'évolution
des tarifs en électroménager
donc je n'ai pas fait de série plus récente
je devrais euh
les taux d'équipement ont considérablement
augmenté partout mais mais
aujourd'hui tu n'as pas un seul foyer
dans lequel vous n'avez pas de réfrigérateur
Machine à laver
etc et tout un tas de trucs qui utilisent
énergie
donc l'industrie fabrique des objets qui
nécessite de l'énergie
et puis ces objets certains d'entre eux sont
va les utiliser même la tondeuse à gazon, etc.
et tout cela va consommer de l'énergie et
alors on voit que
les tarifs d'équipement sont essentiellement
augmente toujours et tout le temps
je te l'ai déjà dit mais je le redis
le divorce est énergivore
parce que quand tu divorces tu dois
doublez les logements et ainsi vous
doivent doubler la consommation d'énergie de
Maisons
s'ils euh bien plus exactement toi
l'augmenter proportionnellement au nouveau
superficie occupée
vous devez faire plus de logements qui utilisent
énergie
et vous devez acheter des meubles pour deux fois
autant de maisons
donc il y a des choses que tu ne sais pas
vraiment double mais il y a des choses qui
tu fais le double
par exemple vous avez deux fois plus de lits
tout le monde dort dans un lit
vous avez deux fois plus d'éviers deux fois plus
beaucoup de lames chaudes deux fois plus et cetera
et tout cela doit être fabriqué et
quand il y a des enfants
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas mais quand
il y a des enfants il faut alors
ils doivent ensuite être amenés d'une maison
à l'autre cela nécessite des
trajets parfois assez longs
comme je vous l'ai dit plus tôt un certain nombre de choses
qui sont considérés aujourd'hui comme normaux
donc je redouble les études de retraite etcetera
c'est de l'énergie
quand le président en 1981 a dit que tout le monde
doit aller à l'université
la promesse implicite derrière cela était
tout le monde aura un travail de bureau
et c'était une façon de dire je promets
votre société d'énergie abondante infinie
puisque je t'ai montré tout à l'heure qu'un monde
avec tout le monde dans un bureau est un
extrêmement
société énergivore à l'époque
quand mithran a dit
tout le monde doit aller à l'université
réalité
il a fait la promesse implicite que nous
serait capable de vivre dans un monde de
machines pour l'éternité
c'est la promesse implicite qu'il t'a faite
regarde ça
l'énergie n'est pas du tout détachable d'un
tout un tas de choses
incluant même la manière dont nous
envisager l'accès aux compétences
donc l'hôpital est aussi très énergétique
intensif
en france l'hopital c'est pres de cinq
% du carbone du pays
empreinte
alors, comme le disent les comédiens célèbres, s'il
est l'aîné les personnes âgées
qui utilisent le plus les services de santé
n'est nécessaire que pour sauver la dernière année de
vie
dans un temps de viande il poserait encore le
question de combien de temps dans un monde de
énergie limitée, nous pouvons continuer à
arbitrer
en faveur des personnes qui demandent un très
machinerie lourde
quand ils sont déjà très vieux pour le
désavantage de tous les autres
y compris les jeunes alors là vous
l'avoir
l'énergie est partout et une fois je l'ai dit
vous ce que nous allons faire un peu
de l'économie
voici la planète terre donc la planète terre comme
le comédien kaloush dirait que c'est carré
avec les yeux dans les coins je plaisante
la planète Terre est composée de ressources dans
une vision anthropocentrique
donc je vais me placer du point de
vue des hommes et du point de vue
des hommes
la planète terre est un tas de ressources
ok c'est notre maison c'est là que nous
vivre ce sont des ressources
auxquels nous avons accès ces ressources
je vais les classer en deux catégories
d'une part les ressources qui peuvent
se renouveler
sur des échelles de temps courtes, je les appellerai
renouvelable et d'autre part
ressources qui ne peuvent pas se supprimer
sur des échelles de temps courtes que j'appellerai
non renouvelable
donc le minerai de cuivre est définitivement
non renouvelable il n'y a pas de grande échelle
transmutation sur terre qui reconstitue
le ou le stock de cuivre
les combustibles fossiles sont renouvelables si vous attendez un
quelques dizaines de millions d'années
ce n'est pas vraiment une échelle de temps courte donc je
les mettre en non-renouvelable
par contre l'herbe ou le solaire
le rayonnement est raisonnablement renouvelable sur
échelles de temps courtes
ces ressources sont toutes gratuites
et ils sont tous les résultats de ce qui a
s'est passé depuis le big bang
être libre
depuis la soupe aux protons du big bang et
tout le reste tout un tas de
processus ont eu lieu
et aujourd'hui nous avons une table de mandalay gratuite
et toutes les combinaisons qu'il offre
nous à la surface d'une planète et tout
cela a été fait gratuitement
à notre arrivée et décidons d'avoir un
activité productive
qu'est-ce que l'activité productive pour les hommes
est de prendre des choses de ce grand choix
de ressources
et transformer les ressources en quelque chose
autre qui est plus intéressant pour nous
que la ressource d'origine
par exemple j'ai des silex bruts c'est
plus intéressant d'avoir coupé des avions
et courir derrière ma proie par exemple je
avoir des cerfs
c'est plus intéressant d'avoir des cerfs
garnitures de bois pour faire un certain nombre de choses
etc donc l'activité productive des hommes est
juste j'utilise les ressources existantes je
les transformer donc énergie de transformation
et donc j'utilise de l'énergie à l'époque
évidemment juste celle de mes bras jambes et
le feu
et j'en fais autre chose et plus
temps nous allons augmenter l'énergie
nous chercherons à avoir à notre disposition afin
je répète 500 000 ans d'énergie
transition
ce qui nous permettra d'augmenter
capacité de production de chacun de nous
nous extrayons donc les ressources plus rapidement et
ils se transforment plus rapidement
dès que des ressources non renouvelables sont
extrait de l'environnement pour se transformer
les faire passer à autre chose
le stock de ressources non renouvelables
descend donc au début ça ne tambourine pas
rapidement même s'il semblerait que
exemple sur silex qu'il peut y avoir
été des pénuries locales au cours de la
paléolithique
nous avons donc pu avoir de temps à autre
pénuries locales de ressources et
ne riez pas parce que
à ce moment-là, ils en mourraient et
avec le temps nous avons aussi compris qu'il y avait
faisait partie de ce que nous avons transformé
qui pourraient être conservés pour accélérer l'avenir
transformation c'est ce qu'on appelle le capital
donc le capital est la partie de la production
qui n'est pas
consommé tout de suite et qui est
réutilisable
pour augmenter la production future afin
c'est super et tout mais nous avons grandi nous
grandir nous nous multiplions nous produisons plus et
plus
et on vide de plus en plus vite pour
stocks non renouvelables
et à un moment nous devenons si productifs
et si nombreux
qu'on commence aussi à vider les énergies renouvelables
actions
donc aujourd'hui nous avons commencé à vider le
les stocks d'espèces par exemple qui sont
renouvelable
on a commencé à vider les stocks forestiers qui
étaient renouvelables, nous avons commencé à vider le poisson
les stocks qui étaient renouvelables et ainsi de suite
nous avons même commencé à vider le sol
des stocks qui se renouvellent lentement
alors oui on commence on a commencé à
vider un certain nombre de stocks a
renouvelable
et donc j'ai dit transformation alors j'ai dit
énergie
mais j'ai dit transformation donc j'ai aussi dit
produits de transformation indésirables
parce que quand tu te transformes il y a
toujours un point où vous avez des indésirables
sous-produits d'une transformation
ces sous-produits indésirables de
transformation ont été donnés
nom dans notre langue ça s'appelle
pollution
donc la pollution est tout ce qui est indésirable
sous-produits de transformation qui est
ceux qui auront un effet que nous
ne cherchons pas et seulement que nous
ne cherche pas mais plutôt ça nous agace
en gros la pollution c'est tout ce qui agace
la merde de nous alors mis en plus
termes orthodoxes
ce sont tous les produits que nous allons
introduire dans l'environnement et qui
aura un effet
de dégrader la qualité de
actifs restants
c'est la pollution à l'intérieur que vous pouvez
rentre dans cette définition
changement climatique érosion de la biodiversité
la surpêche et ainsi de suite dans cette affaire
l'économie que nous avons construite et
que je détaillerai dans peu de temps
consiste à compter le débit annuel et
vu que c'est tout ce qui compte
et j'expliquerai pourquoi fondamentalement nous comptons
le moment où nous nous transformons parce que
la transformation est l'action des hommes et
l'argent ne paie que les hommes
donc dans cette affaire, nous avons décidé que
le seul repère
de ce flux physique d'un système que je
vous présente ici
est la contrepartie monétaire du
flux de transformation annuel
et ce flux annuel de transformation en
le jargon des économies s'appelle pib
c'est la contrepartie monétaire donc nous
aurait tout aussi bien pu avoir un
responsabilité si je dirais compte
positif ce que je fais négatif ce que je fais
détruire et le jour où la valeur marginale
de la dernière voiture que j'ai construite
est inférieure à la valeur marginale du
derniers morceaux de minerai de fer cuivre ou
lithium ou vanadium chrome et fossile
les carburants que j'ai utilisés pour fabriquer cette voiture
j'ai arrêté de faire des voitures et je vis heureux
pour toujours
avec les voitures existantes
vous voyez clairement que ce n'est pas ce que nous
faire en fait le système économique est un
absolument
système illimité rien dans l'économie
le système dit quand le pib atteint 80
trillion de dollars sur terre ça s'arrête
nous avons fait un potentiel infini
système et c'est pourquoi il est si attrayant
alors pourquoi avons-nous fait cela
parce qu'il y a deux siècles quand nous
commencé à théoriser l'économie
certain nombre de personnes qui ont fait le
observation suivante
ils disent que l'économie est la gestion
de ce qui est rare
et où se trouve il y a deux siècles
le facteur humain nous avions beaucoup d'espèces
beaucoup d'espace beaucoup de mondes
les états-unis étaient à peine au
début de notre colonisation la russie est
immense et ainsi de suite
nous ne savons même pas jusqu'où vont les océans
donc pas de problème sur les ressources
ce qui est rare il y a deux siècles, c'est
facteur humain donc les économistes deux siècles
il y a comme monsieur le dit qui a écrit très exactement
ce qui est écrit ici
ben ils se disent en premier
approximation de commande
je ne regarderai que la limitation
venant de l'arrestation des hommes, je m'en fous
condamner
je ne le compte pas et si je considère que
la ressource est un infini avec lequel vous êtes d'accord
moi toute variation d'un stock
est zéro delta s sur l'infini toujours
fait zéro
donc je compte pour zéro les facteurs
qui ne viennent pas des hommes
approximation du premier ordre qui
est encore celui de l'économie aujourd'hui
donc je vais dire quelque chose qui va
rendre très triste le directeur des études qui
vient d'entrer dans la chambre
tout ça fait qu'on t'apprend
à l'école a tort quand il s'agit de
approchant
le système humain dans son ensemble lorsqu'il
vient d'aborder les compromis au sein
le système humain
ça marche quand il s'agit d'approcher
la totalité des hommes
dans leur environnement, il dit seulement
bêtise c'est juste pas fait pour ça
donc en d'autres termes l'économie que je
appris à l'école que tu apprends encore
aujourd'hui
est que le système productif est alimenté
par deux facteurs de production
qui sont le capital humain et le travail humain
et cela suffit pour remplir
supermarché
il ne tient pas compte des machines
ne tient pas compte des ressources
il s'avère donc qu'à l'époque nous
aurait pu gagner la bataille d'une autre manière
il s'avère qu'il y a deux siècles, m.
charles dupont
étudiant de l'université polytechnique
devant une très bonne personne
baron de sa profession il fit une première
calcul de conversion en esclave
équivalents donc à l'époque il n'a pas
appelez-les équivalents d'esclaves, mais plutôt
équivalents de travail et donc monsieur le japon dit
je vais chercher en france et super
grande-bretagne moyens de reproduction disponibles pour
nous en plus des hommes
donc il a tout compris
physique et je vais les convertir
en équivalents de travailleur humain donc je prends
la population
je fais d'eux des travailleurs humains et d'ailleurs
Je compte
il comptait les enfants pour un quart et
femme pour la moitié
et nous nous demandons si c'est
d'où vient l'expression mon autre moitié
depuis
quand nous parlons de notre importance à jamais
non vraiment je veux dire
d'où pourrait-il venir sinon
pourrait jamais aller bien peut-être comme toi jamais
avoir un couple je suppose que cela pourrait être un
explication
de toute façon certains demandent c'est là que ça se passe
vient d'encore
il prend la population et il aussi
prend
les axillaires qui étaient à l'époque
bateaux
mâles etc après mr dupont dit
si je prends la population et le
axillaires
alors ça devient normal que super
Grande-Bretagne qui a une population de
à peu près la même taille que celle de la France
a déjà une production industrielle
trois fois supérieur
c'est normal car il n'y a pas que les hommes
qui travaillent
il y a aussi des animaux de trait mâles et
bateaux
si à ce moment-là on avait écouté mr
double
et pas mr dire qu'il n'est pas tout à fait sûr
que nous aurions construit l'économie
de la même façon
ce n'est pas complètement sûr et ce que le
physicien
dit est que ce que j'ai sur la droite
sont mes 92 éléments du tableau de mendeleïev
arrangé d'une autre manière que ce que j'avais
dans les ressources initiales c'est juste que
es-tu d'accord avec moi il n'y a rien
autre que les 92 éléments d'un mandalay
table dans tous les objets du quotidien
rien
vous êtes d'accord sauf que nous ne les avons pas trouvés dans
cette forme dans l'environnement
donc je les ai trouvés dans un formulaire et je
les a transformés
donc pour ça j'ai besoin de trouver mon 92
éléments de la table de mendeleïev
ça s'appelle des ressources et transformer
eux
ma capacité de transformation ce sont les
calculs d'ordre de grandeur que je
vous a montré plus tôt
ça vient pour l'un des muscles des hommes
et pour 200 de iron man
c'est-à-dire sauver un parc de machines qui
nous avons construit
c'est le rapport de un à deux cents
que j'ai développé pour vous
plus tôt
l'investissement en capital se fait comme le
repos c'est
ce bâtiment qui est un élément de
capital a été fait comme le reste par
transformer les ressources naturelles
ce bâtiment comme le reste est fait par
transformer le minerai de fer c'est-à-dire
le fer et l'oxygène s'arrangent d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire des pierres
qui sont des ressources naturelles qui doivent
dis peintures
transformer les ressources naturelles, etc.
fait exactement de la même façon
c'est juste qu'il ne se détruit pas
lorsque vous l'utilisez, ce qui signifie que pendant que
nous sommes dans cette salle pour votre plus grand
plaisir aussi bien que le mien
ça ne s'effondre pas ici tu comprends
qu'il n'y a pas que des hommes qui sont
facteurs limitants du système
dans le monde moderne, l'énergie est une limite
facteur d'un système
autrement dit si je prive ma flotte de
machines d'énergie je priverais mes
système productif de son système productif
capacité
même si les banquiers sont très gentils et
même si les chômeurs sont prêts à partir
travail
que ce n'est tout simplement pas suffisant dans le
monde dans lequel nous vivons
si je prive le système de ressources pour
exemple je n'ai pas de poisson pour attraper le pib
du phishing est nul
le pib de leon le brexel est nul je
signifie qu'il doit changer de muscles et
expédie à
deuxième navires mais sinon c'est zéro et
cetera et donc si vous ne le faites pas
avoir des ressources dans l'énergie que vous aurez
avoir une fabrication
même si vous êtes très motivé
travailleurs et même si vous avez très
banquiers sympathiques
donc historiquement jusqu'à présent tout cela a
pas été un facteur limitant la limitation
le facteur a bien été les hommes
vous avez ici une reconstitution d'un pib
depuis l'an zéro c'est à dire
depuis la naissance de monsieur jésus christ et
alors que nous n'en avions pas
auxiliaires mécaniques dans des
nombres il n'y a pas de croissance
la population est raisonnablement stable à
cette fois aussi
à cette époque puisque les hommes sont productifs
comme il est musclé
système et non plus le plus peuplé
pays du monde est
a le plus grand pib de la planète et
c'est
la chine absolument donc la chine aujourd'hui dit un
chose dans le concert des nations
écoute ne nous fais pas rire pour deux
millénaires auraient été la dominante
puissance économique de la planète
ce n'est pas parce qu'un siècle de pétrole a mis
les états-unis à notre place mais c'est
va changer notre vision du monde
donc d'abord nous allons reprendre
chez nous et après on parlera c'est
brusquement de cette façon que
les choses sont très peu d'aides mécaniques
très peu de croissance arrivée massive de
les aides mécaniques et les combustibles fossiles et
claquer
les modèles économiques disent que nous allons
avoir trois pour cent de croissance pour l'éternité
alors ne riez pas il se trouve que je fais partie d'un
organe appelé le haut conseil pour le climat
on nous a présenté il y a trois semaines
le National
stratégie bas carbone développée par certains
tes aînés à qui nous avons forcé de
dire
pour vraiment obligé de dire que euh mais pour
diminuer fortement pour diviser par
six ou sept la quantité de fossile
énergie que nous entrons en france
augmenterait le pib français c'est dedans
pour de vrai parce que les modèles économiques
te dire que
parce que les modèles économiques peuvent vous dire
que nous pouvons augmenter le pib en divisant
l'énergie par 10.
puisque l'énergie n'est pas un intrant, il n'y a pas
problème
pas de problème en attendant ce n'est pas
ce qui se passe donc je vous présente
le meilleur modèle macroéconomique
monde appelé une ligne droite
vous avez ici en abscisse le montant
d'énergie utilisée par les hommes c'est-à-dire et
je répète avec des machines leader en service
et en ordonnée la valeur économique de
production
qui suit de façon quasi linéaire
très simple vraiment très simple c'est
valide
en valeur absolue et c'est aussi valable en
variation que vous avez ici en vert le
variation annuelle de la quantité d'énergie
utilisé sur terre
c'est-à-dire la variation annuelle d'un
nombre de machines en service
et en bleu la variation annuelle de l'humain
production économique
tu vois ça donne moi celui que je te donne
l'autre et te donner l'autre je te donne
toi un
d'accord, je vais vous dire d'une autre manière
les euros ne mesurent que monétairement un flux
que les kilowattheures mesurent physiquement
donc ce sont deux unités de mesure mais
regarde la même chose qui est
un flux de transformation auquel je reviens
mon
courbe que je vous ai montrée plus tôt
approvisionnement en énergie par
personne et cette fois nous en ferons une autre
commentaire vous voyez que sur la période
menant au choc pétrolier l'énergie
l'offre augmente de 2,5
par an et par personne, cela signifie que le
parc de machines par personne
augmente d'au moins 2,5 par an
tu as un peu d'énergie
l'efficacité qui doit cela signifie
que tant que vous n'en avez pas
les facteurs limitants et les ressources à
transformé
la production physique par personne augmente
d'au moins 2,5
par an donc la valeur monétaire
contrepartie de sa production augmente
d'au moins
2,5 par an en fait, vous verrez cela un
un petit peu plus
après les chocs pétroliers vous voyez que le
le rythme ralentit
en fait il ralentit complètement pendant
pays de l'ocde
les pays dits riches occidentaux
pays et le surplus que vous avez
ici
est la montée de la Chine, puis plus tard de
dans d'autres pays émergents
cela se traduit par le boom du
quantité de charbon par personne
qui est un effet moyen en fait dans
pays occidentaux la quantité de charbon
utilisé n'augmente même pas diminue a
peu cependant ça explose en chine
et aujourd'hui la chine utilise la moitié du coke
consommé dans le monde
à ce stade, le système commence à ralentir
un peu mais dire que nous
continuer à avoir une augmentation
en production physique par personne beaucoup
plus faible
et beaucoup plus faible que le taux de
redistribution à laquelle nous étions arrivés
habitué
pendant ce temps c'est-à-dire que
nous avons organisé dans tous les états occidentaux
du monde
un État-providence
plus ou moins plus ou moins comme moins
bien-être aux états-unis et plus
bien-être dans les États scandinaves, mais
dans tous les pays du monde, nous
organisé un État-providence
qui redistribue une partie de ce qui est
produit et le taux
de croissance de sa redistribution
est lié au taux de croissance de
production c'est-à-dire quelques pour cent
par an
et nous ne mettons pas dans le système le
possibilité de le corriger rapidement
si la croissance s'essouffle mais doit
dire que nous ne le disons pas aux fonctionnaires
on vous prévient si les copines s'essoufflent
augmentations de salaire pour ancienneté
ça arrête on ne dit pas aux retraités qu'on
vous avertir
si le rythme de la copine s'essouffle
automatiquement vous commencerez votre retraite
plus tard
et être payé moins et ainsi de suite et ainsi de suite
nous ne disons pas toutes ces choses que nous disons
non non si petite amie est à bout de souffle nous
continuer à vous payer le même et
vous majorer d'ancienneté dans le même
chemin
à ce stade, nous devons trouver l'argent
quelque part et on s'endette
dans tous les pays occidentaux, la dette publique était
inexistant avant les chocs pétroliers
il apparaît et pousse bien très petit
avant les chocs pétroliers
il apparaît et pousse partout donc c'est
non seulement les politiciens français qui sont
incapable
il apparaît et grandit partout dans tous
les pays occidentaux après les chocs du veau
exactement pour cette raison
parce que le taux d'augmentation de
la production par personne devient
insuffisante pour assurer le taux de
augmentation de la redistribution
par personne à partir de 2005 et je dirai
vous dans le prochain cours pourquoi
l'approvisionnement en énergie par personne commence à
devenir à peu près constant
de nouveau dans le monde et en fait c'est
en déclin dans la zone ocde je vais vous montrer
système juste après et à partir de là
s'effondre complètement
crise financière massive du citron
frères qui est une conséquence de ce que
Je te dis
et je te montrerai pas trop longtemps mais
chronologiquement et non une cause
la mort commence à exploser nous arrivons dans un
chose inconnue depuis très longtemps
longtemps appelé
taux d'intérêt négatifs, etc. et c'est le
réponse du système
au fait que nous avons construit avec
quelque chose qui dépendait de
abondance d'énergie et que cette énergie
l'abondance commence lentement aujourd'hui
lentement aujourd'hui pour se défaire
quand tu auras mon âge on va
passer en overdrive dans ce domaine
et c'est pourquoi ton avenir ne sera pas
l'extension tendancielle du passé
donc quelques graphiques pour finir vous avez ici
la variation du pib par habitant dans
monde
donc de production économique par
personne au monde depuis 1960.
vous l'avez ici en variation annuelle et
je mets dedans
orange les moyennes sur trois périodes
qui sont
avant le vieux choc entre les vieux
choc de 79 et l'ancien choc de 2007
et depuis le choc pétrolier de
il y a 2007-2008 petit artefact que je
ne parlerai pas d'aujourd'hui parce que c'est
trop long
mais la dette est quelque chose qui le rend
possible de générer du pib sans
production
je veux dire c'est un peu compliqué mais euh toi
commencer à avoir un effet frontière
tu vois qu'au temps des 30 glorieuses
années l'énergie grandit
fortement par personne et la production
par personne augmente encore plus fortement
puisqu'il y a l'efficacité énergétique
le gain entre les deux ingénieurs sait faire
faire
des voitures plus efficaces qui ont le même
quantité je veux dire qui conduit plus avec
la même quantité d'huile
s'il s'agit de la même voiture ou d'une plus grande
voiture chère qui choisit le même
quantité d'huile
ensuite vous voyez que l'énergie par
personne augmente moins vite
c'est en fait un pour cent plutôt que
0,5 et vous voyez que le pib par habitant
commence à grossir moins vite
et depuis euh donc c'est très contrasté
là tu
voir qu'il y a un grand épisode de
volatilité
tu vois ça descend en fait il y a
deux régions du monde qui ont évolué
d'une manière très discriminée par rapport à cela
moment
l'ocde et le reste donc je vais vous montrer
où nous vivons c'est l'ocde
so ocd voici comment implique une première
partie de l'ocde c'est-à-dire l'europe
union où nous vivons
jusqu'à ce que le pétrole choque l'approvisionnement en énergie
par personne augmente fortement
il augmente très peu entre les
chocs en 2006 et en fait vous voyez que
le maximum est en 2006
deux ans avant les rivières citronnées ce n'est pas
burgers au citron qui ont causé l'économie
crise qui a réduit le montant de
l'énergie utilisée c'est la contraction de la
approvisionnement disponible
d'énergie qui a ralenti le pib
qui a rendu les bars incapables de rembourser la dette
qu'ils ont commencé à contracter lorsque le
économie
ralentit pour la première fois en 79 et
c'est un fusil à deux détentes
en 79 nous avons commencé à nous endetter pour
compenser le fait que l'énergie
cesse d'augmenter
et en 2006 le moment où l'énergie commence
pour diminuer nous n'avons plus de capacité
s'endetter davantage à droite
vitesse
pour rembourser le schéma de Ponzi que nous avons
commencé à créer
et au cours des dernières années, vous voyez un
effet dont je vais parler ensuite
temps qui est la nouvelle offre du
marchés mondiaux de l'énergie
du pétrole et du gaz de la roche mère dans le
États-Unis
bien surtout de l'huile et ce que vous voyez dans
L'Europe 
est que le PIB par habitant augmente
fortement au cours du 30
années puis l'énergie par personne s'arrête
augmente mais le PIB par habitant continue
augmenter
et vous voyez que depuis 2006 l'augmentation
a été presque nul
et d'ailleurs la production industrielle
en europe aujourd'hui est encore inférieur à celui
de 2007
10 kilomètres en camion aujourd'hui en europe
sont inférieurs à ceux de 2007.
l'indice de la construction aujourd'hui en
europe est inférieur à celui de 2007.
donc une partie de l'augmentation du pib que nous
avait depuis 2007
est faux pib c'est un artefact comptable
lequel est
fondamentalement une mauvaise solution pour l'inflation si je
peut le mettre de cette façon
et à ce stade vous demandez au grand
les bretons êtes-vous heureux et les grands
La Grande-Bretagne vous dit non
je vous rappelle que lors d'un référendum en
général tu réponds à celui qui demande
question vous ne répondez pas à la question
le président l'a appris à ses dépens
et en général quand tu quand tu demandes oh
et d'ailleurs le premier référendum en
France
sur la constitution européenne vous
souvenez-vous du résultat, nous avons donc simplement demandé au
remettre en question d'une autre manière
mais donc le référendum est historiquement un
très bonne façon de répondre à la
questionnaire et non la question donc
les anglais disent à la personne qui demande un
question
nous ne sommes pas satisfaits de la façon dont les choses
passent par le chemin
à partir du moment où le pib par
habitant n'augmente plus
et vous créez un espace de libre circulation
dans un lieu
où vous avez une différence de un à
cinq entre ce que les gens de l'est
gagnent et ce que les gens de l'ouest
gagner que pensez-vous
il arrive que ça s'équilibre
alors où quand vous êtes dans une expansion
univers c'est bien parce que tu peux
augmenter les revenus des gens d'un côté
pendant que vous continuez à augmenter ou à
au moins ne pas diminuer le peuple
revenu de l'autre côté
alors quand l'espagne et le portugal entrent dans
l'union européenne dans une période de forte
croissance
le pouvoir d'achat des français peut
continuer à augmenter en même temps que
le pouvoir d'achat de l'espagne années
augmente fortement
mais quand tu laisse entrer en 2005 c'est
dire deux ans
ou un an avant l'énergie européenne
maximum les pays de l'est
leur disant venez dans notre danse votre
le pib augmentera les mêmes fois
que les heures continueront d'augmenter et
puis bam l'énergie par personne commence à
déclin
à cette époque, le pib de la région n'est plus
augmente votre vase communicant
effet s'applique et quel que soit l'est
les pays prennent les pays occidentaux
et donc il y a deux façons de le perdre le
plombier polonais vient à londres
et il vous donne ce résultat et le
deuxième façon de le perdre est
renault investit en roumanie et à ce
le temps que les ouvriers français commencent à crier
et ce sont les deux façons que vous avez
un processus de rééquilibrage qui s'applique
et ce n'est que le début aussi longtemps
comme on dit et je n'essaie pas de faire bon marché
la politique ici mais je te dis juste
que tant que nous restons dans un espace où
tout le monde bouge et paie
comme il veut bien tu as initial
différences de potentiel que vous ne pouvez pas
homogénéiser par dessus
vous aurez des rééquilibrages avec perte pour
un certain nombre de personnes
donc la tentation du brexit le met en italique
sorts espagne sortie ou
quelle que soit la douce sortie augmentera
et toutes ces pressions augmenteront
à cause de ça
et à la source tu trouves de l'énergie quand
vous faites une analyse des tendances
vous voyez d'ailleurs que cette variation
de l'approvisionnement en énergie par personne
c'est les cheveux à la tendance très forte que je
reviendra au cours suivant
qui s'exprime depuis des décennies
ici vous avez une courbe qui vous donne
la variation de l'approvisionnement en énergie de
l'Européen
ce n'est pas l'union c'est la variation
pour
les 50 dernières années ce que vous voyez c'est que
la variation avec
les grands écarts suivent une tendance qui est
fort et puis moins fort et moins
et
de moins en moins fort jusqu'à ce qu'il atteigne
un point où il entre en négatif
territoire et d'ailleurs à ce moment-là
nous commençons à avoir quelque chose qui est
raisonnablement volatil
si on se dit que cette seconde
dérivé a de bonnes raisons d'être
représentatif de la dynamique interne
du processus
à ce moment tu te dis que
le reste de l'histoire est que l'énergie
l'offre va continuer à baisser
de sorte que le taux de croissance du PIB qui était
faible et plus faible au cours de la même période
continuera de décliner et de passer à
territoire durablement négatif
donc la vie qui nous attend toi et moi pour
les prochaines décennies à venir
si tout va bien kama aussi
a toutes les chances de ne rien chercher
comme ce que je connais depuis que je suis né
c'est-à-dire que ce ne sera pas un monde de
expansion mais ce sera un monde de
contraction
nous allons donc avoir besoin de votre créativité
génie parce que je vous assure que
gérer un monde en contraction est une façon
plus terrible
comme un exercice d'optimisation sous
contraintes lors de la gestion des mondes
qui s'agrandit donc nous allons vraiment
avoir besoin de toi
nous aurons aussi besoin de moi mais nous sommes vraiment
va avoir besoin de toi dans le sens où
nous allons vraiment avoir besoin du meilleur
élu apporte dans le pays pour s'attaquer
l'un des problèmes les plus difficiles que nous ayons
va devoir résoudre ce qui est de garder
un système
plus ou moins stable dans un contexte de
contraction des ressources disponibles
je peux vous assurer que ce que vous avez vu dans
les parties écrite et parlée du
examen d'entrée c'est une petite bière à côté
je prends l'espace ocde dans son ensemble et je
finira avec ça
mêmes motivations mêmes punitions ça
fourniture par personne
augmente jusqu'à 79.
passe par un maximum en 2006. ce
est également formé aux états-unis
aux états-unis, l'approvisionnement en énergie
par personne a traversé un maximum
deux ans avant les frères citron j'insiste
tu as aussi cette évolution qui
reflète en fait une évolution de la tendance
qui se déroule depuis très
longue durée
et très probablement la même chose
se passe dans ce domaine là
et dans le monde dans son ensemble il y a tellement
ce que je t'ai dit lors de cette première
module est que le monde dans lequel nous
en direct
était notamment autorisé non seulement mais était
permis notamment par le fait que nous avons
trouvé
quatre poches de soleil libres sous nos pieds
comme le dit très bien les trois autres petron
bien
mais c'est juste un carburant sans combustible fossile avec un
pouvoir calorifique très élevé donc un
très grande capacité exothermique
qui nous a permis de transformer à un
vitesse accélérée
toutes les autres sources également gratuites
que nous avons trouvé sur terre qui a
nous a permis de construire l'économie sociale
système dans lequel vous avez grandi
c'est-à-dire la plupart des gens dans les villes
la plupart des gens
dans les activités de service tout le monde mange
steak à chaque repas
les personnes ayant beaucoup de temps libre et
demandes des employeurs dont vous avez besoin
médecine les travailleurs non assurés qui peuvent
les deux soient accordés sans problème
c'est le monde dans lequel vous avez
grandi et d'ailleurs le principal paritek
programme d'échange international depuis
il faut des avions pour ça
et la façon dont je compte
flux de transformation
est un chemin que j'ai construit par construction
sans limites puisque la seule chose qui
était vraiment au courant de la question
disons simplement le fait que la terre
est de treize mille kilomètres dans
diamètre et non quatorze mille ni
quinze mille je l'ai ignoré j'ai frappé
sous le tapis
donc basé sur cet axiome qui n'est qu'un
approximation du premier ordre que j'ai raffinée
ma vision pour
deux siècles mais sans remise en cause
l'action fondamentale qui est que
la nature est libre
donc évidemment je ne vois pas cette limite
puisqu'il n'est pas dans le système
dans le prochain cours nous ne regarderons pas
ce
qui est l'une des premières limites
facteurs d'un système c'est-à-dire
pollution
nous nous concentrerons sur un point très spécifique
pollution appelée changement climatique
donc le changement climatique n'est qu'un aval
conséquence de ce flux de transformation
dans le prochain cours ce que nous allons vraiment
regarder est un goulot d'étranglement
qui s'appliquera à terme en amont de
le système
qui s'appelle l'approvisionnement en fossile
énergie
nous pourrions aussi bien sûr si nous avions le
le temps regarde l'offre en métaux c'est
un autre facteur limitant possible de la
système
l'approvisionnement en espèces est un autre
possible facteur limitant du système
et ainsi de suite
mais on va regarder on va
discuter sur le
amont en énergie fossile comme pour
disons en capacité de transformation
donc voilà c'est la table dans
que nous serons
pour le prochain cours auquel j'invite
avec plaisir
bonne nuit
toi